you may hear a slight chirping
throughout this episode it is in fact a
cricket living in the walls of the
warehouse creating an echo chamber don't
be alarmed this is the last episode in
this warehouse the cricket will not be
moving with us to our new song
[Music]
thirsty
hey what's up guys dopezioli here and
welcome back to another episode of the
dope as usual podcast we wanted to start
off this episode by saying thank you to
one of our new sponsors this is liquid
iv i'm excited to tell you about this
new product because it's something that
rosie and i have been using for years
the way i would put it is liquid iv is
the fast cure to dehydration anytime i'm
feeling like i know i haven't been
drinking a lot of water i'll pop one of
these in my water and if you know me
personally you know that's true i have
these at my house i have them right now
at my house so if you've never tried
liquid iv or if you're somebody that
already buys it and you want a discount
code listen up right now you can leave
your house go to walmart and buy these
bags and yes they're awesome
everything's great but it's normal price
liquidity.com and use the code at
checkout yola and that is 25 off your
entire order let me drop some knowledge
on you guys real quick liquid iv pack
has more vitamin c than an orange and
more potassium than a banana this is
non-gmo gluten soy and dairy-free 100
vegan
and i'm
this was laughing and i'm not saying it
100
but sometimes in personal experiences if
i've been super hungover these help me a
lot all right i'm just going to say it
so like i said you can hit any of your
local walmarts you can get all the
flavor there's lemon lime strawberry
watermelon guava pina colada there's a
bunch all right your local walmart has
all of them or like i said earlier go to
liquidive.com and don't forget use the
code yola at checkout that's 25 off your
whole order and i know a lot of you have
already seen this you're like damn they
got liquid iv to sponsor the show yes
and thank you guys so much for making
that possible for watching the show
thank you for supporting the brands that
support us
[Music]
oh [ __ ] here we are what's up guys
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast i am your host thomas dobasiola
whatever you want to call me i am here
with mario neil drastic graphics
guys that's it it's the end of season
one
this is it this is the last episode guys
this is episode 36
end of season one and we are here with
oh gee what's up full
you have to talk
i heard nothing
could you hear me now yeah i can hear
you better this was all embarrassing
[ __ ] but still agrees to come back every
[ __ ] time
and he's the most talkative [ __ ]
yeah he can't pretend there's no cameras
just look at me how about that i'm not
even tripping on that
all right if you weren't here we had the
first episode with og
and if you know who this is if you all
right how about this if you don't know
who og is he's my friend and he's been
in many [ __ ] videos
all the dope is yellow [ __ ] for years so
that's why so many people
no oh gee and the last time we brought
him on it's one of the biggest episodes
we have it's number three i think the
biggest episode
people love to do i [ __ ] loved it
everybody loved your stupid ass
chimichanga story in your [ __ ] school
buying everybody's [ __ ] that's just
tight yeah but uh guys here we are
we're gonna start it off last episode
this full hates being on camera as you
can see him doing this right now
like he wishes he had a [ __ ] blanket
to cover his eyes i could see it on your
face
are you sure are you sure first question
how come you just watched your episode
this week
took you five months to watch a damn
episode guys
not kidding hey do you watch it
no i don't wanna i don't wanna i sound
stupid but you don't you sound like a
normal human what the [ __ ] i guess just
hearing yourself you know what i mean i
guess i get anxiety bro when i start
looking at i'm like what the [ __ ]
you know and i went oh [ __ ] damn i was
talking about that [ __ ] this
and i turn it back off well you're fine
everything's hilarious that's the first
question actually i just finished it
today see
he just finished it today all right i
just wanted to make sure
you see exactly what you're talking
about or something
you know i don't want to just took him
so far are you rolling a joint yeah hell
yeah i don't think i've ever seen your
roll joint on camera before
all right it's a finale guy this is the
last episode
we have a bunch of stuff to do we have a
bunch of stuff to smoke we have a
shitload of stuff to drink and this
fool's three drinks deep already because
really calms the nerve really
i've watched you do three
um
so guys real quick this is the last
episode thank you for being here for the
entire season 36 episodes
countless [ __ ] hours of us talking
[ __ ]
and we're back so since the last episode
light it up
i'm gonna start off with quite a quite a
chunky joint this is a almost a story
time joint it's getting closer so
you ready you ready to talk
you sure
you sure are good do you would you want
me to you want to hold your hand
if we hold both hands like we're praying
would it make you feel better
you sure
no i'm good all right if i if i button
up just my top button will it make you
feel more comfortable
yeah okay i got you oh ashtray get your
astra
here we go so you just watched your last
episode what you think about it
that was pretty i thought did you say
too much [ __ ] that you shouldn't have
said
do you feel that way because i had a
couple people on here go y'all probably
shouldn't have talked about that man i
go i'm not taking it down that's what
you're asking
yeah no i ain't tripping that [ __ ] over
that was what over 20 years ago
no the episode was a couple months ago
oh no i'm talking about what i'm kidding
i'm [ __ ] kidding full
so you just watched it everything was
cool man it was fine
you're not crazy you didn't say anything
that's gonna get you in trouble yeah no
i wasn't tripping on that that's this
episode but i would just maybe just you
know sometimes i say dumb [ __ ] and
that'll make sense yeah every day i
understand all day so yeah exactly
every day a lot of people don't
understand my humor no they don't and
they go what the [ __ ] man like the
let's just say this i went to a sporting
event with og the other day
i went to the monday night raider game
with og against chargers og's a die hard
raider fan also
you know when people say god i hate
raider fans man
he's one of them all right let me just
say that he's one of those guys that
makes you go [ __ ] raider fans you
guys lost you're still talking [ __ ] yeah
for sure
yo all right i'm gonna just tell you
this marty
i knew i don't want to go other places
beaujee
when it involves sports the second mindy
and rosie went to the bathroom
this fool started hounding the man in
front of us
all raiders no he was in all raiders
gear but he was laughing
at the bronc at the chargers guy yelling
he's like yeah this shit's hilarious
because the guy's all first ah
and he screams like go
and the guy laughs and then she goes
sorry do you want fool just like in his
ear serious and the guy goes i'm just
watching the game man all polite goes
i'm a raiders fan dude i know he wasn't
a raiders fan he said he said that you
tell that to my garage that's what he
said he's all i have all nothing but
raiders perfect
you know he was like i guess he's
was mad at the raiders or something
he was climbing his boy next door that
was all still being a die hard
okay but that's what he was doing i
don't know what he said hey who said are
you on because he's like you're putting
your own [ __ ] he said say that to my
garage
he said all my posters up i'm a raider
fan yeah yeah but nobody goes i'm just
trying to enjoy the game man that's what
he said to og as in yo can you please
leave me the [ __ ] alone sir i'm just
trying to enjoy the game man 20 minutes
late they went to the bathroom never
came back no actually they were there
till the end
they never came back who sat in front of
us mr fab too short
yeah but no they they were back they
never came back are you drunk they gave
me a hug when they laughed you're a lie
[ __ ] you're a lie on the boat
anyway guys i have snapchats
periodically of every quarter they never
came back i'm gonna put them in there so
people know you're a damn liar they
never came back they came back nobody
did it trust me
i was the only one not shipping gave me
a hug said cool see you next game and he
kissed you on the cheek right no no we
just you know
you guys tapped his shoes
raider hood is where you hold each
other's pockets real quick yeah gotcha
let's get sick i like that
i'm just looking back at justin
so um
so yeah i knew i knew right then and
there and the older white man the driver
you're a dick
we were walking out she asked them if
this was my limo that's not what you
said we walked by this older white dude
big tall dude standing oh she goes it's
wrong full you look scared
yes right remember that old see she's
even laughing is that what i told him
yes and he goes i'm fine he goes sorry
you just look kind of scared right now
oh you know what yeah
i know but you look scary and when you
because he was looking like everywhere
like the way he said what's up man you
look kind of scared as we walk into our
car and go full
leave him alone i'm not scared
because i seen the way he was looking
around something like oh [ __ ] you look
scared he was looking for the guys you
know if my appearance isn't [ __ ] i
tell you bro it just sends a whole
different message people get it all like
oh [ __ ] yeah your facial expression said
where are you from no that's what the
facial expression said
no no i promise you yeah you don't you
can't see your own face
oh he did that oh he did inadvertently
press this [ __ ] dude he did
and then i won't say who but so and so
drove off like a [ __ ] dummy
before we drove you know how embarrassed
i was marty i didn't tell you about it
yet
i was so embarrassed leaving the game
i won't say what it is but the person
driving us
ran over all the cones
here and dodging cars to run over cones
holding up the line [ __ ] with people
driving through cones stop to get out to
take all the cones from out from under
his car whipping around people to get on
the [ __ ] freeway i smacked my head
against the window three [ __ ] times
it's the driver you hired
no i would've took uber no i'm saying
this is he's our homie that was like
y'all got the van
and i went why the [ __ ] am i in the car
i had my head down like this the whole
way we left
i was so embarrassed dude
i was so [ __ ] embarrassed
because you know what we were already
all on top
yeah i didn't want to say that he was
drunk
exactly i didn't know he was [ __ ] up
he looks fine no he looked fine right
when we got on the freeway went is this
full [ __ ] up and that's when i'd say
turn on the radio i i felt bad after but
you'll turn the radio down hey
anybody tell you you're a terrible
[ __ ] driver he goes no well you're a
[ __ ] terrible driver yeah and then he
didn't say anything went oh he took that
to heart
and then he started driving normal the
rest away went oh bro i was just [ __ ]
around i'm sorry i didn't meet him yet i
didn't mean to make you upset i was just
being dumb but also you're a bad driver
yeah well you know [ __ ]
it was raining i mean if you're pulling
out goddamn cones from underneath the
car he made him pull him out because we
can hear him
and he goes hey i don't want that
[ __ ] chp he would have been seeing
those cones get him out so he just
took all the cones and we you know we
took a little shortcut we took a
shortcut you know the lane that's
blocked off yeah they cut through the
entire lane we didn't wait on the way
out exactly we were those guys with a
car full of liquor and beer and drink
and
weed lit weed
that was the ignorance lane yeah yeah
that was the lane for all the ignorant
people they followed us too
some people did follow us and they were
the same as those people that said [ __ ]
yeah he's doing it let's do it it's
crazy because i would rather have walked
home than if i knew that was gonna
happen yeah actually it was so
embarrassing bro good driver bro you
know what i mean
he is a good driver after all that's
some fun that's it so [ __ ]
i guess that's fun
i guess that's funny look around you
have a little fight you know parking lot
full of cops on horses yeah let's just
drunk drive through a [ __ ] comment
yeah no don't get me wrong he thought
about it the next day he actually
literally did tell me about it he's like
[ __ ] you know i didn't think about he's
a good thing we got off and took those
cones off because and now he would have
been dragging with those cones that was
one of the best things i heard that i
had that i did that night i go yeah [ __ ]
you see why i chill by myself in high
school sometimes you know
but man
you know hey he was he was he was quick
to think about that too so you know
we're good
so too short
i don't know randomly we were sitting
there oh geez scared off the man he left
the seat and then mr fab sat in front of
us like oh wow
mr fab i used to watch you in concert
man and then too short can't go
hey man you should watch your
unconscious man said the same [ __ ] wow
that was pretty cool just because it's
just because it's [ __ ] too short it's
awesome
um my joint didn't even never happen by
the way too short please come on the
[ __ ] podcast a short dog
that was pretty dope of him being there
he pulled up he even said what's up
right yeah he was cool
he's asked me right because he was all
[ __ ] up
he said it right
um
that was the raider game
i guess that was fun all right yeah how
drunk were you you said you're drunk i
was i was completely sure
[Music]
but they had they ran out of vegan food
inside it was all out so sit there just
just drunk and wanted to throw up all
night too drunk there's nothing to eat
we took some shots in there i don't know
what the [ __ ] that was bro took shot i
didn't take shots yes we did we took we
and you took a shot so we got one more
double that's right yeah bro
but i don't know what the [ __ ] that was
he did that extra for us because he was
cool remember that
after that oh man we took a triple shot
i drank before we got to the seats
yeah that's why
you chugged it right there you left the
cupboard yeah that's why i was so [ __ ]
up
anyway that was that was cool
all right but that was a raider game man
we just went i really
like i always say
i hope for people's sake the raiders do
good
i hope for the neighborhood's sake the
raiders do good yeah because if not
there's a lot of fights after because
they're mad
i grew up around raider fans
it was pretty cool how many people went
to the hospital that game
your dad sent us the article
you know how many people got rushed to
the hospital at that game oh [ __ ] like
six different people what charger fans
probably no no mostly raider finance
fighting raider fans
which is hilarious yeah for sure that's
like
[ __ ] erica throwing pics just like
push stop
that's pretty local right yeah but i
don't know i hope they do good man
because
they just they it's been sad i'm pretty
sure you know they got vegas involved
you know vegas does a lot raiders are
going to do good they can have a really
bad team at the new regu the new stadium
they can't have an okay
i'm excited dude the raider's been
sucking for a long time
so
we'll see marty can you put the notes
back
sorry my bad they turned off um
so
so far
so this joint is getting me gelato yeah
you wrote it too big gelato what
uh it's a gelato octane octane
gelatinous no you know what motivation
no it's a it's a king lotto king louis
gelato that's what we named it
okay who makes up your names i don't
like it make a better name
i mean sure i think it sounds pretty
dope no that doesn't king lotto
i mean
wait what did you say you're going to
change your twitter name though you know
if the weed's good then you know it'll
take you'll do for them that's true
what'd you say this morning i was half
awake and we said something and you're
asking me my twitter name it's a stretch
zilla
something like that this full crotch
zilla or something stupid i was happy so
this is what happened to me yesterday i
told you a little bit this is what
happened to me
i'm starting a new company my friend
hash house okay
but it's
not delta eight or delta ten i'm not
going to say everything it is i want to
[ __ ] it up
but this cannabinoid
is not thc
test detectable
so you can eat this product smoke this
product and it doesn't show up on a drug
test
it's a new canopy that came out it's
federally legal
i tested i've been testing different
candies and chicks we're starting a
brand a full-on brand like with us
behind it
and i ate about 800-ish milligrams
yesterday but remember sunday i went to
bed you know ate food like a human
normal
woke up monday met you to go to the game
we didn't really eat because there was
no vegan [ __ ] i ate some guacamole with
you guys so i went home too drunk
couldn't eat because i was [ __ ] up
woke up tuesday morning didn't eat went
straight to the meeting about the delta
[ __ ] hadn't eaten yet i drink a protein
shake thing
i get there and forget oh yeah we're
gonna go see venom with jess and diana
so i'm rushing back
800 milligrams on an empty stomach and
then started eating more because i was
hungry so i was like oh yeah they're
medicated [ __ ] so probably ate more than
that
got so high because i was on an empty
stomach for a whole day
i almost threw up my uber on the way
home after the meeting i almost had the
guy pull over on the side of the five
because i was gonna throw up i was so
high and just you know where you're
spinning like go to sleep go to say go
to sit go to sleep you're just trying to
pass out as bad as you can but in the
day in an uber and then i went oh my god
i gotta go the bathroom no
rosie was there i even went like this my
head hurts
and i'm gonna go to the back i'm gonna
shut my pants and i just sat there like
this
the whole 40 minute drive from the uber
and i'm thinking yo if you throw up it's
250 you have to give this man right now
[ __ ] and then
i woke up and i was almost home thank
god i was so high i passed out so good
thing that the edibles and [ __ ] were
about to sell work
i got so violently high went to the
movie
passed out during part of venom woke up
all [ __ ] oh god that's right i'm at
the movie theater with everyone
went home i fell asleep at nine o'clock
last night and i woke up at 11 o'clock
this morning
i slept for 14 hours last night
edibles work
how many milligrams you think i probably
like a thousand but a thousand shouldn't
hurt me that much it's because no no
food and i wasn't drinking water or
anything i drink a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] lap i know but usually i'm
knocking down two or three and being
like oh yeah [ __ ] me up
this one and it's not even like thc it's
a different cannabinoid so it's not
psychoactive but
it is
so that was my day so i haven't eaten
food since i today i ate the sandwich
that was first thing i used on sunday
it's been three days [ __ ] that's how
i've been feeling
all right
friday i [ __ ] and then pld on friday
i made fun of him on on friday because
he was at work
i thought i said 100 milligrams and it
was a thousand i chucked half of it and
he's just sitting there
did you get [ __ ] two days later
i'm like
hey the [ __ ] uber savings that [ __ ]
[ __ ] horrible don't talk [ __ ] to your
friends when they're [ __ ] up all right
because it's coming it's coming for you
dude i regret that one bro i regret
making fun of you again bro i make grant
making fun of me
well i did the [ __ ] uh
actually the video comes out tomorrow
you know the pod challenge right duct
tape paws in my hands oh yeah
as i was taping it i realized they were
a gram each i thought they were halves
so i'm like okay a full gram not bad
because you know a pen [ __ ] you up a
gram of pen well you're done for the day
you're so high
and as i'm taping i'm like wait that's a
big pond and i look at the package it's
a [ __ ] full grain what was it like
resin or light resin but still dude two
grams to the face in the sun
i was walking around echo park and
pumping the swans by myself in a
two-seater so i'm trying to go as hard
as i can i had a horrible headache
because i'm sitting there just you know
i'm pouring sweat in the sun in echo
park and there's supposed to be two
people doing and i'm doing it by myself
so he can go film from the drone
you're all duct taped up i was duct
taped up sweating my [ __ ] ass off
sweating my ass off in the sun you look
so peaceful
every time the camera comes i try to
like
all right
and not just be ah
[ __ ] war cry that's how i felt and i
dropped off nikita the filmer and
they're like yeah he can't come back on
bike but we've been film we've only i
almost said we've been filming for 10
minutes but we've only been out here for
10 minutes no he can't get back on i was
like go get the drone well he's gotta go
to the bathroom and he jumped off and
then he went and got the drone okay
now without it they wouldn't let me film
[ __ ] no
hell they're gonna be film getting high
on their swans
around families
did it look like you were doing that
with me of course
what are they gonna do
come get me like hey get over there like
all right pump my boat
i'm not pumping [ __ ] i'ma float over
there
hey keep filming what are they gonna do
to me nothing
but also i don't wanna be rude so that's
why i try to hide it you know me
i never want to be rude and [ __ ] to
people especially if they're just doing
their [ __ ] job
but that was my day
all right are you ready well
i have a question for you
all right so guys little
story i knew this guy one time that grew
the best og i ever smoked in my life
and he's a [ __ ] because he was like
you know what all these talents and
knowledge i'm just not gonna [ __ ] use
it it's this guy
that's what you've ever had
this
hence the name og oh she's a master
grower bro
and the true og is where it all came
from
and it's funny because i have a friend
named justin also that makes a lot of
noise
[Laughter]
sorry guys we have my friend over here
i know your phone came up and he went
i know that's a face you probably made
too you're fine i'm just [ __ ] with
you grow weed
yeah you know i kind of stopped i got
out of it i know that's one thing when i
first met og he had the best weed i had
ever smoked in my entire life the og i
told you where it tasted like you can't
finish the joint
remember those days oil grown yeah hey
lincoln's dream
all right thanks man thank you
that's it i think the first time you
came over remember i think
the first time i won't say everything
but the first time i ever came over i
almost left og's house creeped the [ __ ]
out
i won't say everything because you
probably shouldn't but he said something
to me i went what the [ __ ] did you just
say to me
i started grabbing up my packs i was
like i'm out of here
funny enough i came to sell og weed this
is so long ago that's how i met him i
can't sell him weed
yeah i was actually trying to get him
over there so i was like dude how could
i get this guy to come over you know
cause i was already like creative but
you know not because you know he was
cool we knew we had mutual friends i got
to get this dude over here so you can
[ __ ] see what's up because i got some
[ __ ]
and then i found it like you got the way
better why am i bringing this [ __ ]
wheat over here to you
so was he [ __ ] with you like
no he said some some uh some some some
uh spiritual [ __ ] but i didn't know it
was spiritual [ __ ] i thought he was
being a creep to me
saying some [ __ ] i went who says that as
i'm packing my [ __ ] up my it's nice to
meet you bro and my other friends like
what are you doing i'm like i'm [ __ ]
leaving
right in front of him right in front
like i'm out
and he goes
bro
uh you know you know you don't know my
humor i'm [ __ ] kidding
oh man i thought you were being dead
serious i'm [ __ ] out of here and
that's how i met lg
and the pack was i think overpricing he
still bought it i don't know he dumped
it too but i remember thinking
all right this guy knows enough people
if he's gonna dump it all right cool and
then on the way i'm like you grow this
why the [ __ ] am i bringing this to you
and i just started [ __ ] buying weaver
mim
seriously he was just sampling yeah he
was just trying to get different things
it was just lower they were they were
lower packs too my people they were
already tired of og yeah they were i had
different [ __ ] where's the flavor so
this guy would say flavor yeah because
up north over here
yeah cause up north is flavors down here
is oh geez that's why i never had og's
until i moved down here
when i met him
but so ready why is your weed so much
better is it the tech
what makes your weed better i mean
no no there's got to be something i mean
i don't know
not only that he sinks to it no he posts
music
it's boutique
exactly you know i mean i had it was my
back room you know yeah i mean it was
pretty big you know enough for a six
lighter but it was good you know what i
mean
before you go i forgot to mention it
that [ __ ] cricket's going crazy i
forgot to mention it if you guys hear a
noise
there's a [ __ ] cricket in this
warehouse and we don't know where it's
at and it's so loud it's not static it's
trolling us it's just and it only
started 20 minutes before we started
[ __ ] filming we've been here all day
guys i'm sorry that
that's a [ __ ] huge cricket
continue sorry before people keep typing
77 your mics are [ __ ] it's a cricket
season two no guys season two's in the
inside there's no more crickets anymore
so yeah like i said it's just
i believe that the smaller room the more
loves you the more attention you give
it's true though but we both know a guy
yeah well you know
we both know a guy that has small rooms
and they always come out shitty uh i
mean that's because man won't say her
name so much passion aaron
you just gotta put your whole full time
into it
aaron put your time into our friend as a
master grower aaron's a great grower
every [ __ ] crop since the time he
stopped growing has been i mean since
the time he we realized he was great
has been dog [ __ ]
every time because it's a small room oh
you know i got this i got mites oh it
was too hot but but you should know that
it's your room so i'm talking [ __ ] to
you right now you better make your grow
better i'm going to start calling you
love my trash
not love my cush all right that's to you
the pcp the platinum cherry kush
i don't think i tried that one yeah not
regular pcp no no i know but you smoked
that one
[Laughter]
look at me left
yo i haven't even smoked this thing
um so why so i mean you're like 90
percent organic i mean i've been doing
this i was doing this already for over
for a good minute let me say hello but i
was doing this at least a lot of people
you know
coming over my pad and you know just
you know selling packs and doing all
that [ __ ]
you're leaning towards your mic
i said you know i said
[ __ ] this you know i like i had to
change it up you know basically i needed
a whole new changeup you know what i
mean and then there was some [ __ ] going
down you know so you know what this is
not good it's just gonna get me you know
i'm the one growing here you know so of
course you're gonna say well you just
stopped growing because it got hot yeah
it got hot and everything and not only
that but like i just figured i always
wanted to change already bro it's like
[ __ ] believe me i mean you sit there all
day at that point there's just i mean
there's like people right now they're
into selling packs and all that i mean
damn and i did it so much that literally
[ __ ] said i'm
[ __ ] tired of it same you know i mean
it gets boring afterwards i mean like i
love i just don't like people's [ __ ]
yeah i mean just other people's [ __ ]
yeah that's all it is it's other people
that's it how many hours do you think
you've lost waiting on a [ __ ]
apartment
you know what i'm saying
hours bro hours driving hours of them
[ __ ] waiting around [ __ ]
everything bro just
you know
so many i don't know how many how much
money i've given gas stations for drinks
waiting for [ __ ] and gas
stations
probably like a 10 racks just on drinks
over the course of 20 years
think about it i'm not 20 like 15.
yeah bro [ __ ] that's it bro i just
kind of wanted to change
how did you say why you stopped growing
selling weed like i said i don't know
what you do that's the reason because
like i said it got hot and you know like
i couldn't have i mean i was i was
playing i was doing legit you know i was
still paying my my light bill legit you
know i wasn't
we're stealing no [ __ ] no i know that's
not paying legit so my my bill my
[ __ ] library would come pretty high
you know what i mean
12
15
16 2000 sometimes and
[ __ ] you know i mean and
just for the [ __ ] being so hot you know
what i mean [ __ ] they're gonna they're
gonna see all that like who's this guy
right here and what is this oh [ __ ] look
at his [ __ ] his light building you
know what i mean so sorry guys
i kind of just i said you know what [ __ ]
it taking it down i'll just start buying
my own emoji you know i mean i still
have a lot of friends a lot of people
that you know good girl that grow good
og you know what i mean
where the [ __ ] are they at man cause i
can't find no good i mean no they're
there they're coming already they're
coming just
like i said everybody wanted the flavors
for a minute so yeah everybody went to
the wedding everybody started winning
going remember the wedding cakes right
we were squishing it in your garage
going
oh she's going to disappear because
wedding cake is trying to take over
right now remember that yeah 2016 17-ish
that [ __ ] sucked we're over there
smoking flower rosin in your garage
trying to do gram dabs he can't finish
them so you know oh [ __ ] hey there's a
video on the internet that says a lot
there's a video right now that says dab
fail fire warning go watch that [ __ ]
it's this guy that's me yeah but that
was the definitely i hit it at a real
high temp
so otherwise i would have smoked it off
not true i don't think you would have
smoked it i did though
in like 50 other videos where i've taken
gram dabs then you can't but this is a
shadow let's just say uh
i could dab more than you inspired and
it's fine
you know what
i'm gonna say maybe maybe maybe even
saying maybe
accepts defeat and i went there
oh no that's all i wanted to hear man
that's all i wanted to hear
you know baby i gotta let my i gotta let
my son have his way get the [ __ ] out of
here
that's a new generation get out of here
yeah you know what i mean you know of
course well yeah bro you know i mean
there's prototrans sure of course i just
don't want you to cry
i just want you to cry my shoulder again
for me taking bigger bombers than
bang rips you
not really too
i'm not it's not the 90s what you always
say not the 90s anymore yeah i mean i
could take them but just sometimes
they're just a little too harsh on the
throw and i'm like [ __ ] this yep small
better weed man
just gonna sit there
[Music]
i caught this [ __ ] smoking
backwards in this office
i don't give a [ __ ] what you say yeah
you know a lot of people can see even
his wife's like
they have backwards i mean i don't i
know you can't see her but i see this
question you know they leave it to the
green and this guy happens to come
and he sees him
are you ready marty marty during this
section since we're allowed to edit this
i'm gonna give you all the backward
pictures i have of him and just throw
him in
look at his face
oh [ __ ] okay so back to my question you
didn't answer why is your weed better
than most is it because you're so
[ __ ] organic honestly i think it's it
could be the organic and i mean because
then by organic you're not pumping it
full of [ __ ] you're making your own
tea for sure yeah just you know yeah old
school because a lot of people don't
know that's real and you know how many
people out there go what do you mean
make your own tea what the [ __ ] you
talking about i mean [ __ ] explain it
explain it you can you can [ __ ] throw
even
live [ __ ] you throw like not live i'm
saying you can throw like fishes you can
throw all kinds of [ __ ] in your dirt you
make that soil [ __ ] alive bro i mean
[ __ ] that plant's gonna [ __ ] love you
bro you know what i mean a lot of people
don't understand they're just they're
just using synthetics
i'm not saying that nutrients don't work
of course they do but you know i mean
there's a lot of remedies that you could
do too you know i mean
also and i was [ __ ] a lot way at the
end with hydroponics while starting
against hydroponics at the end too
and then right before [ __ ] i shut
everything every time i walk in your
room
the last run you did was the one that i
remember i mean how many years has it
been i still remember the wheat i
remember the bag
that [ __ ] was fire ooh that [ __ ] was
fire
it was lunch the plants were just and
that's when they started coming out like
you know i started getting the og's i
started doing them with hydro and [ __ ]
bro [ __ ] i went hydra on them and
they [ __ ] came up
dude they were so
[ __ ]
fire
old school
the og that just makes you like is this
a chemical
it's like on your lips like you know
i love that literally i had one time i
sold one of my boys
just the ground because this guy wasn't
really like had too much weight i sold
him a gram one time and he [ __ ] um
he went some party in pasadena and [ __ ]
he said literally he was going up a hill
cops are coming down the hill they
stopped him they literally turned around
stopped them and they [ __ ] told him
where's the [ __ ] wheat yeah i got it
so we got a little bag right here bro it
looks like a little ziplock bag that's
true
but back then you know at that time you
know [ __ ] the grams were [ __ ] 20
bucks they were [ __ ] you know the
people still instagram sometimes you
know
bro [ __ ] cops are going crazy brother
like where is it at we could smell it we
could smell it he goes nah this is it
you know what this is no [ __ ] at the
end bro they were just like [ __ ] i've
had
but that's all i got that [ __ ] was
humming man just literally passing by
saying that
oh yeah i've smelled weed passing in
people's cars before in traffic i it's
rare when i go damn because you should
go oh damn some trash weed but it's
normal weed i miss a snob or weed stop i
[ __ ] admit it all the time i'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
but
my lungs hurt man when i smoke trash
your lungs hurt when you smoke hybrids
it hurts me i'm surprised this one
doesn't burn my chest
yeah this one's actually a pretty good
one
but yeah too much i don't [ __ ] with
hybrids
just give me headaches
um i got a stupid question real quick so
when you're throwing weed you're growing
weed you get some seeds of that that o.g
[ __ ] that og that you had yeah every
time you grow to the seed are you able
to keep the seeds going or in a way
i had some seeds bro i just had some
seeds and um
you know [ __ ] i kind of [ __ ] up i you
know [ __ ] you know i should've did it
myself but you know what i mean so i
really don't know if i can they told me
they didn't pop and [ __ ] so i was like
[ __ ] it i'll never trust anybody to say
your seeds didn't pop well you know
that's what it is
that's like somebody making five
thousand of your cds and go oh bro they
didn't sell at all well yeah and i don't
need that thank you i don't i'm not
gonna be interested
they were pretty old they were like i
want to say
they were over [ __ ] they were they
were but i'm saying can you keep your
strain going for a long time like does
each plant come with a plant you can cut
it
i mean a clone off of it
fantasia
it's
oh okay that's all the same [ __ ]
thing well the same [ __ ] the truth the
truth that he may remember i told you
there was a guy who knew that had the
truths and those were one of the best
we've ever had in my life
yeah this guy got some he he got to get
some of my last of my [ __ ]
and that's right after that i was trying
to get it for him and i couldn't get it
from now because no one had that [ __ ]
bro everybody was just trying to grow
like you know [ __ ] throwing
phosphorous little trying to grow the
most out of [ __ ] trying to get
[ __ ]
20 [ __ ] well not [ __ ] let's say 30
pounds out of a [ __ ]
six lighter [ __ ] you know what i mean
six liners
i've seen some crazy [ __ ] i've seen like
15 lighters 45 pounds
damn that's disgusting mondo burger
[ __ ] you know keenan and kale well yeah
that come up every god i'm upset okay
but you know mondo burger from the movie
when they cross the street they're
pumping it full of [ __ ] they get the big
burgers
that's what phosphor load is
hey this one light i needed to produce
three pounds you're not thinking about
the plant anymore you're not thinking
about the patient you're thinking about
money it's gonna be more like a pound's
gonna look like a half a pound a half
pounds of that hard rock weed do not pta
psa do not smoke hard ball weed
i got [ __ ] up that is the full of
chemicals and [ __ ] if you can go
like this
and your nug does that bounce [ __ ]
like an everlasting gobstopper
don't smoke it
so that's what he means by three pounds
of light you should be getting one
one to like one six yes
and you feel like damn is that a nug
that's just full of [ __ ] you know
you grind up a nug a huge nug and it
turns into nothing yeah that's full of
chemicals
when it's that hard
that was going on so remember that one
good old genome and this guy was
remember the purple ones
[ __ ] you know take root no yeah
yeah i would grab him by a shirt and
push him against the wall but where the
[ __ ] the weed at remember i said that
to you
in front of your kids occasionally now
you know i find it you know and i'll
bring it uh-huh you know all i know is
the last pound of food i bought from
somebody
tastes like straight dog [ __ ] which one
was the last one i'm not too sure i
bought a pound of og yeah yeah that was
that was [ __ ] cool
i didn't you know what actually because
you you took it i didn't get to try hey
man i was trying to be vague and say i
didn't buy it from you
this fool just straight up says well
when you took it from me like [ __ ] oh
gee i was trying to be vague man
i know it's it's legal patient and
patient i get it it's not like we're out
here trapping to each other exactly but
i was trying to let you be [ __ ] yeah i
was trying to be vague so when i gave
you that pound for the donation like
dick what was it half pound and it was a
half pound
and then i got a half pound for rosie so
i got a full pound
hey man it's legal out here yeah well
i've seen you you didn't see you take it
off until you split it right yes put it
now are you trying to be vague [ __ ] off
[ __ ] you look at it
he's keeping his glasses up from the
side
you went you went you checked it out you
[ __ ] looked it in yeah and i went oh
gee is it fire though
i didn't smoke it i didn't smoke it yet
i said is it fire though and you go bro
it tastes fine it's got that good taste
that you always had a good [ __ ] taste
i'm not a lime [ __ ] i just look
back at the person who knows you best no
actually you looked at it you smelled it
and you said i'll take you remember i
told you and i said did you smoke it
though when i left and went god [ __ ]
yeah it's one goblin game here i bought
that pound when goblin got here no you
know what that one came from like a
different room that's right so it didn't
taste the same as like the last one like
okay
before that no actually a week before
that one came down like a week late so a
week before that it was it was you know
it was good and then a week after that
it it just he got one of those and i
didn't get to try it because he took it
so i was like but i asked did you try it
yeah it's great it's got a good taste
yeah because i thought it was still the
same you know until he's [ __ ] awesome
i think i got a lot of people
complaining
you know what it could just be that [ __ ]
was horrible yo i'm sorry i'm sorry
audience sorry audience for this
[ __ ] going on right now but
i'm trying to talk about how i misplaced
a couple racks on some trash that i
still have it's just in a jar festering
in that back room because i don't like
it got em
yeah no actually i told you go pick it
up look at yourself that's great that's
fine it's [ __ ] awesome
i even said full
i'll just buy a queue
come on is it is it fire because the
last time i got weed from his guy
it was [ __ ] fire and i only bought
two zips and i went back and tried to
get more so that one's gonna go
i would have bought two packs of it or
something [ __ ]
and then i'm like oh the next one he
gets and that was the one and it was dog
[ __ ] i went to merced with it smoked
something went uh
done i'm good yeah i heard about it i
heard it was like ashy black and
everything right i heard about it it's
because i faced time to win what the
[ __ ]
he told me about it
yeah i heard about it someone else gave
me the complaint and then another two
weeks later somebody else gave me going
i was like [ __ ] you know what it was
but it was too late you know it's funny
because i went and got a pound from him
because it was like that you know the
caregiver [ __ ] like yo here's a half and
here's a half rosie and he's like i'm
out of week and i get a half i went yeah
and i just gave him a half back remember
i gave him a half back so he actually
did so
yeah
yeah we're just putting all our business
out here all right here we go hey i was
trying to be vague you [ __ ] it up
so um that was my question that turned
into 60 [ __ ] minutes yeah so you mean
basically that was it i had to just
basically stop doing that that's why
like i said now you know you know now i
manage to shop you know
yeah one of the biggest shops going on
to my next question all right all right
here we go
how was it running a legal shop
when you were in the black market
because you are for everybody out there
i'm not trying to say oh gee you should
be a [ __ ] drug dude oh geez to be a
[ __ ]
how do you call a caregiver because he
would grow his little plants
and it would be for donation to the
people that you knew the same people
would come through and get weed so it's
not like we're out here just getting
packs moji and putting his business out
there it's [ __ ] legal he's a
caregiver with all the [ __ ] permits
it was all legal it's all cool that's
why i never felt weird like flying when
i used to leave some random dude's house
and buy packs oh he's legal ah all right
all right caregiver
i mean it was fire so i'm like can i get
in bulk
yeah let me get more
so how is it running a legal shop versus
that because i for me
my perspective is one of your walls has
a lot of scuffs from your feet being
right there and you're just chilling
going [ __ ] best job of all time i'm
[ __ ] bored
that's what it looks like to me you look
bored i'm talking about my this shop
that i run now yes you look bored how is
it compared that's cause i mean look at
once you once you come in
after
seven o'clock eight o'clock i'm chilling
already i mean like you're not gonna
catch that's where i'm like already
sitting down watching just the cameras
and [ __ ] you know
but you know this guy doesn't go early
he shows up at two one company usually i
show up at six a.m
i'm there i remember opening the arena
back and
i actually opened the gate for him to
come in to work now usually after seven
thirty seven o'clock i'm chilling bro
i'm either [ __ ] just on the camera
checking everything out
it's the 90 angles i mean you guys it's
the best vibes ever down there you guys
it's a great show you get the food going
yeah it's pretty cool how is it like it
what do you what do you think i mean the
legal shop versus
the trap [ __ ] well the legal ish trap
[ __ ] you should do well
i mean when i was uh
when i was
no it's a big difference bro that's for
no comparison that's what i'm [ __ ]
with
i mean [ __ ] what do you mean i mean i'm
trying to tell you do your favorite
close your [ __ ] eyes real quick
just throw this in your head
like so basically i mean from going from
what i did to now i mean [ __ ] it's a
whole different it's a whole different
vibe now that i'm doing the whole legal
[ __ ] it's just
it's something that i've always wanted
right so it's not like
i can [ __ ] uh actually uh okay i'll
pull back how about yell at too
you're not you're starting to answer the
question
actually this is something i actually
you know what a matter of fact i knew
this was going to happen in some part of
my life you know that i was going to run
a legal shop one day and a big shop yeah
and you know the funny part is that i
always knew who i was going to run it
for him no yeah we have to say his name
but we know we're talking about you know
so you know i always knew like [ __ ] you
know and you know he was also you know
he was
in the streets too so you know i mean so
you know i always knew about him you
know he was actually one of my friends
friends so i always you know one day you
know [ __ ] you know because he's the
legal guy yeah he actually ran no more
shops and you know he was you know he
had the [ __ ] going he was popping off
you know
so you know i just knew always like you
know it's just
just the same thing like when it comes
back to like the wallpaper you know i
mean the paper story i told you same
[ __ ] you know when you were younger
somebody's going to send me papers to
smoke for one day i mean i know i mean i
got it from chinchinchang nice dreams
yeah and he comes in he says the [ __ ]
jobs he goes yeah they give me free
papers and you know and you know yeah
what do you get i just get free papers
you know to roll joints and i was like
[ __ ] i would say that like damn when i
first would see i'd be like you know
[ __ ] one day [ __ ] someone's gonna give
me spray papers because that's how much
i love [ __ ] weed
and i mean [ __ ] it just it just like it
just comes in it it happens bro like you
know so that's why i always knew that
you know i was gonna run a shop one day
you know
yeah so so um
running there oh
[ __ ] so you know what that train means
it means you get back on topic
[ __ ] how is it how do you feel
about running the shop toward the legal
shop well i mean i feel better of course
i mean [ __ ] what is that what is its
differences well the difference
obviously like you know you feel a lot
safer now that's what i'm getting at
like you don't have to be worried yeah
for sure it's like all those words are
gone i can sleep at night now i come
home go to sleep sleep at night you know
before it was like i couldn't sleep bro
every night was like a [ __ ] you know
just thinking when are they to come they
come here and knock down my door today
yeah today today
that was my whole every damn day that's
how i that's how i
saw that lady twice in two weeks [ __ ]
i'm gonna get my door kicked in you know
yeah so worst feelings just you know
that was just always and now bro i mean
like
now i just you know go to work come back
and i can literally go to sleep not
worry about it not worrying about my
phone ringing people coming you know
nothing like that how is that it feels a
little different
how different man that's that's that's
like the best it sounds so either
it's the best thing not getting through
four o'clock calls going
for weed [ __ ] it's four yeah
plan accordingly you dick yeah for real
like who calls somebody at four you got
weed or are you awake
[ __ ] you it's not meth yeah for sure
yeah i'm telling you i had one time this
one guy when i you know i had this one
guy come to when i was still in
apartments when i moved out like when
first before i moved in back to the
block
i'll stay in these apartments and i
would have you know
just i had this one chef guy bro
literally at four in the morning would
come knocking for weeds knocking yeah
you know
no not i mean because back then it was
still you know i think cell phones
weren't still as you know they were
coming in that's fine you know what i
mean so yeah he came
how you had to how you had to ask for
weed oh yeah man [ __ ] and you know what
i mean i would trip out like damn bro
it's four o'clock in the [ __ ] morning
bro going to work he said no he wasn't
even going away he's just like oh bro
you know i'm just trying to smoke a
chair and i'm like dude he's smoking
sound bro you smoke no i wouldn't back
then i would talk like bro you know
where you're [ __ ] you're smoking
crack food or are we trying to come down
or what yeah that's been right you know
he even got offended by because i told
him that you know so i think that's like
that's a reasonable yeah it was his
nationality
like in a bad way oh because he's a
black dude
yeah he was like because of his
nationality
[ __ ] just say [ __ ] black dude
with crack and mexicans with meth
everybody knows the drugs that serve oh
but i mean i i told him because dude i
mean you're kind of my cousin
was like literally he got pissed and he
never came back because you asked him
that yeah well okay i told him bro oh
wait wait wait oh it's the 90s yeah oh i
can see how you gotta feel that crack i
[ __ ] have a job [ __ ] [ __ ] you
yeah i know okay it's funny because i
would get offended too everybody
i think so yeah i think so inconsiderate
that's [ __ ] yeah yeah you know and i
was trying to be funny though
yeah it was
very local in the 90s bro
so how are the customer comparisons from
customers and black marketing customers
illegal because i've been there with
this wild [ __ ]
like the black market was more like your
friends and people that knew your people
the same no matter what everybody that
would come had that respect no matter
what you know i mean nobody and it was
different you know i mean
i think it's a lot different now from
what i deal with now
you know now i deal with patients
[ __ ] man you know i'm talking [ __ ] for
me and i'm just like sometimes you know
i don't get me wrong you know i [ __ ]
you know like
my old school ways to try to come in you
know but then i catch myself and i
[ __ ] you know i'm like all right
chill you know what i mean you mean like
weed snobs like people come on no not
even that so we get some pretty well
we're talking about [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] trying to test you and
[ __ ] bro you know
i had people come in there and they try
to tell me like oh how much is this i'm
like oh it's 35. no it's not i'm it's 25
i'm like it's 35 years old i'm from here
and there i'm like i don't kill [ __ ]
where are you from robert what gang i'm
from food you're at the store
[ __ ] and you know he got all mad
but at the same time after you know i
was thinking i was like damn you know
what [ __ ] you know i don't know these
[ __ ] guys you know i mean [ __ ] yeah
probably nothing to lose you know yeah
it's not even that it's like you're just
doing your job like i don't own the
story i can just drop the price for you
it's federal it's a federal store
it's [ __ ] it's pretty local i'm
trying to pay the government i'm not
going to give you a discount i deal with
some i deal sometimes with some you know
and then there's some people that are
that are mentally sick sometimes too and
those i perfectly understand yeah that
when it comes to that i got that you
know i mean
you know i'll fix it for them because
you know they're not trying to [ __ ]
extort you how about this angle with his
hand hitting the camera sorry i'm
watching him all right i don't know i
was just in the back of my head you're
good you're good yeah
um you're fine do you think um
so i've been there
when you go oh it's this crazy lady
again
this lady
you know maybe we shouldn't put it all
out there you're not [ __ ] yeah i
don't think we should this lady calls
every day let's just say this lady calls
every day calls it every [ __ ] day
you call your weed shop every day about
nothing
just talking not even just a talk like i
don't really like the price of this even
you who i don't think i don't think i
like the price of that one i think you
guys should change the price of this
call you tomorrow
like online troll but for the phone
shit's crazy you have to keep your phone
on your shop
what the [ __ ]
she's trolling i'm just on the phone
you can block numbers but
you can't block the patient number like
she's just an lady you know you can't
block her number that's [ __ ] up yeah
you can especially you can't even do it
from we want to block it
oh well you can't i'm something you know
i know how to block really yes i'll show
you how to do it
actually you know it's funny because uh
i just seen her yesterday she was still
there
she's still there oh yeah that's because
you see these patients come from way
back you know i mean
yeah the story's been around for a long
time yeah i mean it's been a minute so
actually we got old school patients so
you know i still give them you know i
still give them that love you know what
i mean yeah
so whatever i can do i'll do for them
you know that's what i mean yeah so you
are
oh also in your last episode did you
realize how many times you said none of
me
today yeah actually look at the comments
someone did a counter it was 286 [ __ ]
out of here someone did a counter and it
was 286. yeah
and then someone else did another
counter like
on 320 awesome how high are you guys
that's a big difference well i mean yeah
some discrepancies yeah yeah yeah for
sure he's [ __ ] with you you know what
i
mean
i was just kidding marty likes to call
you our joey diaz
yeah of our show like rogan has has joey
diaz and we have og just to savor
outlandish as [ __ ]
no i love that the world got to meet
[ __ ] og season one that's like i love
that yeah yeah the only other time was
when you did the video with me the 100
000 shopping spree yeah you know that
shit's at like 1.2
oh really yes me making fun of you and
you [ __ ] with me is like one point
the first video
first video he ever edited for me
oh that's right yeah the first time i
ever [ __ ] do all at first wait was
that what it is
for sure did you say it was hall flowers
all right
we went there with [ __ ] face
and guy that runs all the weed [ __ ]
[ __ ] face is my own videographer and
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yes right
yeah i forgot about the only witness to
that whole ordeal was this guy and
halfway through me and the guy yelling
at me and me going
don't kill him don't hit him i've never
heard you hate somebody so much [ __ ]
that guy
i saw this fool do this
and creep away and you went into the
bathroom in the airport you [ __ ]
hey homie
i go [ __ ] we're all cool i mean it's
this boy and i'm like whoa bro there's
something personal here i'm gonna walk
away because even here he goes this
isn't about what we just did yeah what
are you mad about yeah i was like i was
tripping like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] does
that mean anyway i won't get in the
whole story but he's the only one that
got to witness it yeah
and i was like this piece did you know
the bathroom twice yeah yeah
he came back out he went right back
me too
so was i i didn't know like i thought
maybe you guys don't know we had
something to discuss
nothing happened
really that's where i went
huh
and what eddie was he was a threat to
him because i know he was no threat no
no but i just walked away you know what
[ __ ] this
maybe i shouldn't even get involved
maybe no i wanted him out there so he
wouldn't go out so i was like
yo stay out here
like stay out here we don't no don't
leave
because the other guy that was there was
the valet guy for the airport and even
he went
on this clip where i go [ __ ] look over
here full you leave me by myself with
this crazy [ __ ] i don't want i
want to kill him stay over here i want
other people here so he doesn't freak
out as much
and then
what ended it was like i'm trying not to
slam you into the [ __ ] ground but
you're getting on my nerve and then he
just stopped
and then i went i'm gonna choke slam you
into the [ __ ] earth and i just got
like i'm gonna [ __ ] lose that and
then he went
and then we dialed it back and like
thank god og's here man
because i want to [ __ ] murder this
man but anyway that was the first video
he ever edited
yeah we hadn't been taking a separate
uber i called another uber from 50
minutes away and paid for both of them i
was so pissed
all right
we came back from the trip having a good
time yeah right when we land bro it just
boom something happened i was like oh
[ __ ] maybe i don't know something i'm
out of here i'm gonna walk away from
this i don't know what happened though
was all pissed off
i'm like [ __ ] it remember that though on
the uber go bro what the [ __ ] just
happened
remember that you're the only person
that was there out of anybody on the
earth he knows exactly what happened boy
just had a meltdown i don't know he had
a full-on [ __ ] mental breakdown told
me once half of everything i own and i
went
and i laughed at him i went holy [ __ ]
and i started packing my [ __ ] like oh
this whole series i went oh you're
serious
oh yeah you can [ __ ] off and i started
putting my [ __ ] away and i go oh gee
there's another uber here
don't worry bro your uber's pulling up i
got you
get another one
that was it man goddamn that was it was
your boy and then here comes the
extortion we had to pay this man hell of
money
for the footage that we shot oh yeah for
sure yeah remember i had to [ __ ] pay
a stupid ass
so you see
1.2 yeah i'm saying us [ __ ] talking
[ __ ] to each other at 1.2 and now you're
[ __ ] shy
that's what i'm trying to say like that
video is big and now you're like well
you know like yeah i got in the 90s i
had a gun and [ __ ]
that's how you act like
he actually shy on camera but talk [ __ ]
in life in that video you're like you're
like why are you whispering to me yeah
he's looking at him i got a mic right oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] like you saw him put it on
me i said hey i'm mic'd up don't say
anything illegal
every time i mic up around my friends he
goes hey don't talk about nothing stupid
because if someone has the original
footage
they got you they got everything you do
shut the [ __ ] up
yeah because it's scary
because not every legal [ __ ]
does legal [ __ ]
hey you know what i'm saying yeah no
it's pretty good i mean [ __ ] that video
is great all that
all the [ __ ] trapping and all that
you know it's just
it's different yeah it's different now
because it's legal it's like but it's
kind of working
bored of it man
yeah [ __ ] all that [ __ ] bro i mean
literally it was just
for me it was just
bro just driving in hours and driving
about you know a bunch of hours driving
i was doing 600 miles a week you know
what i mean i'm serious like i would be
bad maybe 11 10 o'clock in the morning
and we wouldn't get back so maybe 99
and i had the kids too you know what we
literally have to stop pull over
go [ __ ] in the park or let them [ __ ]
play oh you were that dad
you were the dad with big pants that
pulls him up after his construction job
chat and then sell sex no that's real
it's a real guy no you know i mean i
just [ __ ] hector it was just
and then when i would go to work i mean
[ __ ] i had people pulling up to my job
you know what i mean [ __ ] yeah i'm so
sad acting like you're picking up an
application and i'll be in the restroom
and there you go here you go
you know i remember the ladies one day
the [ __ ] reception she's just like
okay everybody came and asked for
for [ __ ] an application yeah
absolutely yeah you know no interviews
she said there were like uh 18
applications [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] four hours
yo uh let's take a shot
how long have you been here for an hour
really it's been an hour do you want a
shot yes or no
yeah
take one and then no more because you
gotta drive later yeah it's the [ __ ]
season finale
yeah
can we just acknowledge that it seems it
seems like simultaneously ten years ago
and like five days ago that episode one
dropped yeah
bro this is unreal
i can't believe you you don't want a
shower you're drinking wine no i got
someone
all right all right for everybody
driving don't drink and drive
all right this is a psa
don't drink and drive pay attention i
got two more dm since last
episode
two more car accidents while listening
to the episode
but one was not his fault he had rear
ended at a stoplight
it's dead stopped got rear-ended sorry
guys
you did no the uh we have
i always say please be safe on the show
driving
because people got the first episode
someone got rear-ended while listening
they're like yo it's so crazy you're
saying be safe and i got [ __ ]
rear-ended right after
it's been like 12 different accidents
that people dm me their cars totaled
really so think about it how many maybe
something
no no i always say be safe now [ __ ] that
acknowledge it be safe
take your eyes off on the road don't
take your eyes off the road be safe
hey man hey man hold on hold on hey man
can we edit this you know man like just
roll it back
here we go season finale
one hour in one hour in
oh gee you look just like jerry rice
that's just sweet what is that damn the
circle bottle i don't know how to say it
mandala
i don't like it it's a little too sweet
as i said it's pretty sweet but it's
good yeah
it gives you a little late kick yeah
yeah
are you ready
i have a question for you only if you
want to talk about it
because i'm not sure that's why i said
question mark at the end of my uh
notes
can you or will do you want to talk
about the ugly guy in louisiana
ugly guy in louisiana you have to lean
closer to your mind
i mean
yes or no
say it [ __ ] is it a yes or no
louisiana
it was baton rouge when you went to
baton rouge for mardi gras and the ugly
guy in the club it wasn't it was in the
louisiana what was it it was uh it told
me new orleans
it was on bourbon street
yeah it was in new orleans actually you
know back when you were
selling fools enchiladas and [ __ ] in
class and not going to school
new orleans is in louisiana [ __ ]
that's the state that it resides in oh
really yes it is
you know i'm gonna put a [ __ ] map of
the of the continent
right here
that's a [ __ ] fire to come out of
[ __ ] easter eggs [ __ ] hey don't be
putting people down for me so they felt
supposed to geography
[Laughter]
no [ __ ] yes louisiana the guy from
new orleans not baton rouge sorry oh you
know what my [ __ ] bad you know what
i'm [ __ ] you're right louisiana
you're right you know what i was [ __ ]
don't worry no you know what cut it out
honestly no no you have to cut it out
but you know what i [ __ ] dude i'm
telling you bro [ __ ] just my shit's
[ __ ] up but i thought you meant saint
louis bro my bad oh no because i know
what you're talking about st louis too
no yeah so that's right when you said st
louis missouri same you know i mean
[ __ ] i got it [ __ ] confused yeah
okay yeah you're right louisiana you've
been to hollywood new york
[ __ ] tell us about the louisiana
story louisiana so i mean
you have to remember
very intuitive with weird [ __ ]
and the way you explained it was perfect
because i know what he looks like and i
wasn't there the way you explained it
was a story time
you walk into the nightclub with mindy
you go to bat uh to bourbon street
louisiana
and you walk in you said you saw some
darker dude i imagined him as the ugly
the ugly guy that killed patrick swayze
and ghost
the puerto rican dude yeah ugly guy with
the jerry curl exactly is that what you
look like the way you describe him
that's how i feel he looks yeah exactly
like that oh perfect and maybe even
uglier
perfect like the fool in carlito's way
lower reach lower the colder beers are
lower and he cuts that kid's throat
same guy
that's how i that's how i see like the
[ __ ] keeper but puerto rican
from tails in the crypt yeah so that guy
[ __ ] yeah we're in the club and he's
just [ __ ]
actually started off with some with one
of like one of the girls she came in she
put one of those [ __ ] you know those
beats they had she put it on me
you know and she put one on my boy too
and
it's wait you weren't with mindy yeah we
were there but i mean it was more like
we were you know we were dancing no no i
guess like walked up to us and put it on
us so it wasn't they're not just for me
for the story you're with me she was
more like she just can't put it on us
yeah and i was like oh she's i mean she
was pretty hot she was you know she was
a blonde pretty hot tall you know very
attracting lady you know what i mean and
i was like oh [ __ ] okay cool so she
knows she's dancing and she that goes
away next thing you know she comes back
with with this one you know ugly looking
character guy the dude in all white yes
so you gotta describe it though it's a
it's a dirty looking nasty dude
dressed in all white with hella pretty
ladies around yeah so he's either rich
or famous
because he's but as ugly as how he
described him like he's like that older
sleazy greasy drippy gary curl soul glow
guy
yeah and he came up to us and
he he shook my hand and we're like oh
well you know he shook my boy's hand and
when he shook my hand bro i got this
[ __ ] leg
whole different body like i knew exactly
who the [ __ ] he was bro so i was just
like
oh [ __ ] get away from me yeah i was like
damn fool you know i know exactly who
the [ __ ] you are some [ __ ] demon
there's some crazy [ __ ] yeah yeah bro
i mean
and uh hey pretend we're in your garage
tell a story good so i mean
so you know like you know i don't know
just [ __ ] so i mean [ __ ] it just
smells like [ __ ] easter egg
he just he was just too he looked too
[ __ ] damn um he was just like an ugly
guy bro we had too many like yeah like
i want to say three pretty girls bro and
i'm talking like very pretty girls like
i was like he's either rich or famous
yeah or he was [ __ ] to me he reminded
me of the damn devil that's what i'm
saying i'm thinking devil's advocate you
an actual demon
okay like you're saying devil's advocate
that's how i imagine him as al pacino
devil's advocate the way he's moving
around the suit and then he was dancing
and there were just dancing around him
like they were [ __ ] doing the al
pacino
so i mean i was i was just tripping like
okay but i got the word vibe from him as
soon as he shook your hand you knew like
get the [ __ ] out of here i found
something weird like yeah
i know exactly what your [ __ ] man
yeah i meant those people yeah
definitely and you know [ __ ] after
that i want to say a week
well we came back and when i came back
dude the day i landed back over here so
i had some like [ __ ] crazy ass
[ __ ] dream like not a dream i want to
say more like a nightmare you know what
i mean and [ __ ] bro it was [ __ ] like
the same thing like like just pulling me
back now the same guy yeah that same
from that like right when i landed came
home knocked out and i had that [ __ ]
nightmare that he was trying to pull you
back back to new orleans right yeah like
trying to [ __ ] pull me back you know
and i was like what the [ __ ] like like i
was tripping the [ __ ] out bro because i
seen the same guy like how what's what's
the [ __ ] chances of that not even
that
i mean if you want to talk about it what
happened next
[ __ ] i got [ __ ] sick bro
[ __ ]
[Music]
i got some crazy ass [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] with me that happened [ __ ]
you're seeing this fool put some [ __ ]
food on this full loss oh how much would
you lose [ __ ] i think i was about
i want to sell about 230 pounds and i
went down to 170.
damn
quick though like [ __ ] with this what
do you say what'd you say you couldn't
eat you felt like you're gonna throw up
the whole night and you couldn't sleep
this is weeks and weeks
like literally like my [ __ ] arms up
here were like [ __ ] boom i was
[ __ ]
like i thought i was done you know i was
like [ __ ] i literally already had
[ __ ] said you know what i'm done cool
like i i'm like i'm accepted you go to
the doctor and what they tell you hey
tell me you know [ __ ] you're good
you're actually i went to the doctor and
i'm [ __ ] laying there and you know
they take blood and they do all the
[ __ ] you know
test your heart and [ __ ]
and uh
they tell me uh you know they come back
about two hours later you know of course
they [ __ ] with you you know you're right
there
so they come back two hours later and
he's just like
[ __ ] no i'm looking at my shades like
uh what's wrong with you and i'm like
you know what my stomach it [ __ ]
hurts it's been already like going on
five days already like i can't eat i
can't sleep i'm in pain you know what i
mean
he's all like oh [ __ ] i don't know
maybe some atlanta or something i'm like
someone like mylanta or some [ __ ] you
know what i mean i mean like some
[ __ ] melancholy what's that [ __ ]
oh he suggested some [ __ ] like that
40 pounds and he says 40 pounds in five
days no no i still haven't lost stephen
king [ __ ] going on here no no no i still
hadn't lost 40 pounds yet oh i was it
was still like within the five days when
it first started oh so like he came out
he's just like you know what you went to
the doctor right away well five days
when that's what i mean like that's
right away you're mexican
right away is five days yeah for sure
right now that's what i said you know
what i'm going to hospital and for me to
go to the hospital it's [ __ ] as i'm
saying your brown skin says i don't go
to the hospital yeah [ __ ] that same with
everybody in the earth i don't want to
[ __ ] hear what they got to say me too
but anyway so i went and
dude took blood he just said you know
what he goes you're healthier than me
but you can't figure out why you feel
like [ __ ] yeah he goes you're healthier
than me i don't know what you're talking
about he goes man he goes [ __ ] he was
tripping out he's just like [ __ ] and
then when he said that i swear like i
just sat up and i felt like a whole
different [ __ ] vibe a whole different
feeling and that's when i knew i go
[ __ ] that's why that's what i said
doctors are no good because i see how
[ __ ] quick he made me feel [ __ ]
good when he said that
like my whole [ __ ] i just rose after
i got up but then you know of course for
only that night i felt good i went home
yeah nothing wrong me cool cool but [ __ ]
no two days later again boom i fell
again bro it was [ __ ] hurting me
[ __ ] how long did it take you to lose
that weight how long were you feeling
sick oh [ __ ] after i want to say about
[ __ ] it took me a month once after the
month hit you could tell really like
damn fool you're losing weight and i was
like yeah i know
second month [ __ ] [ __ ] what's wrong with
you you know like
and like by the third month everyone was
kind of like [ __ ] fool what's wrong with
this [ __ ] guy
this guy's [ __ ] was right before i
met you yeah
and that [ __ ] was [ __ ] local i
literally
you know i had a just
so are you still having crazy nightmares
and [ __ ] during this time
oh yeah bro i always just [ __ ] have
to see that guy again it wasn't him
again it was just like this [ __ ] real
evil [ __ ] face from some crazy [ __ ]
you know right so that guy came over
specifically to shake your hand for what
because he saw the light around your
eyes it was weird i mean yeah he felt
something in which you know he nobody
could take from me yeah yeah for sure i
get it couldn't you know what i mean
or maybe he did people probably think
we're [ __ ] insane listening to this
podcast huh cause we know what we're
talking about we're like you know like
are these guys just high talking about
illumination
i mean maybe he did maybe evil
[ __ ] saw something he's like oh
i don't like that light coming from this
man i'm gonna go get him sick no i think
he took what i had at the moment he did
because i went down and i literally
thought i was done energy's real guys i
literally thought i was done i literally
gave myself up and i said you know what
if this is it i'm ready i'm cool with it
like there's nothing i can do bro but
i'm not i can't live with this pain it
was [ __ ] painful you know what i mean
so
but it didn't
you know i ended up [ __ ] coming back
for me you know what i mean like i did
at first i did go see a couple you know
i did i just started off you know i want
to go see a couple doctors you know
witch doctors you know i mean yeah
i wouldn't get too into it in here you
know i mean
they helped me out in some what way but
in other ways and i said you know what
you know i'll handle this myself you
know i mean so instead you know so what
was the resolution
actually i just started actually i just
started taking my own family to church i
just started praying for them actually
for this bad cause you know this bad
evil thing
and i did yeah you know i would you know
just pray for him like you know like you
know like
i didn't want someone else doing
anything for me
talking to your microphone so so anyways
um
yeah that was it you know it went away
months later yeah and he stopped having
the dreams after this full start going
church heavy
he started praying by himself and doing
other weird [ __ ] that we won't get into
you know mean i mean i just figured you
know i could do my own thing you know
what i mean i don't need you know i can
it was cool
it worked better yeah you know what i
mean i ended up coming back bro i did i
did come back so he infected you with
some [ __ ]
this is what we're thinking but we think
there's some evil [ __ ] down
there some voodoo fool that went like
hey this fool's like up on his [ __ ] he's
gonna say i didn't even know he's he's
he's awoke yeah they told me what he's
thinking they told me about how new
orleans has a lot of [ __ ] yeah it's
famous for that shot yeah yeah but east
la he's got a lot of
witch doctor people i literally didn't
know like santoria style i don't know
about any of this [ __ ] it won't get you
into it but yeah yeah and that shit's
real i don't care [ __ ] when anybody says
i know too many people that do too many
things
that to go oh that's fake no that [ __ ]
is [ __ ] loyal yeah that means [ __ ]
you're good you'll be cautious with your
time and your energy and what are you
feeling
there's a lot of good there's a lot of
good doctors yeah there's good [ __ ] you
know i mean i mean i totally respect
them you know i mean i've been to some
spots like damn bro really so you're
here on this hill like god damn you know
what i mean i still i respect it bro you
know what i mean i [ __ ] it's real you
could tell it was like a spiritual thing
that was going on even though it was
like man it was like a whole yeah i
thought maybe he might have just took
some kind of took some kind of good
energy maybe he's just testing it seeing
how strong this [ __ ] fool's brain
really never had dreams like that before
of what
like not about that guy like things
terrorizing you in your dreams and then
you get sick and nothing like that
no no
nothing like that you know i mean i felt
like i was being dragged out of my bed
though
damn that was like a freaking pretty
crazy ugh i'm trying to bring you back
ugh i think maybe he just uh i don't
know or maybe he might have just uh
said something said something like like
uh whatever can't say this um
you might have just uh just
awoken something in me you know i mean
that's been there
and that's probably what i've i've been
in situations where they're real [ __ ]
up situations then i get sick of [ __ ]
right after i can see that you get i
don't know if it's you get stressed your
body goes under stress maybe it's stiff
that we don't understand or we're not
supposed to or maybe we shouldn't talk
about
stuff like that
but yes
that's just real man energy and people
i've met people and i'm going that
[ __ ] is an evil piece of [ __ ]
then it turns out that that [ __ ]
is evil as [ __ ]
i find out 10 minutes left but yeah that
fool's kind of wild he's that fool from
like oh
i knew i felt something when i met this
guy right when he shook his hand like oh
this will taught me how to keep these
fools away from me
it's a lot of [ __ ] there's a lot of
stuff you can read books on it and stuff
but yeah it works it's hard though
it's hard to do and it's hard to keep
your concentration on that [ __ ] you
gotta meditate once in a while you know
what i mean find yourself oh yeah oh
you're in yourself and
you're good yeah read there's books out
here it's not why we're saying some [ __ ]
you can't find out there's books on this
[ __ ] but yeah dude some of the [ __ ] you
taught me is crazy and it [ __ ] works
but it's almost draining to do it is
it's yeah
yeah okay i'm not wrong then i feel like
i just worked out like [ __ ] this i don't
want to do this [ __ ] anymore yeah it's
meditation some of this shit's so weird
your mind is [ __ ] it's already like
overworked yeah your brain working it's
like your body working yeah for sure no
i meant yeah i've never actually sat and
meditated although oh don't yeah wait
until you're ready
i i get distracted or i just i'll [ __ ]
that's for a reason
because your body's not ready for it yet
yeah [ __ ] comes in like from like you
know when you can get it there where
it's like i talked about my mushroom
trips where i'm in pitch black
no sound no music pitch black and i sit
there and i just breathe is
my key is to breathe as deep as i
possibly can and let it out as slow as i
possibly can and slow as possible on
both sides
i'm not going to get too into some [ __ ]
but
that's when i had that outer body [ __ ]
when i told you about that motion trip
where i could see myself and when i
moved in my brain i could see my body
move down there
what was that about an eighth it took
over an eighth eight grams oh eight
grand for sure yeah i ate crabs me and
rosie did together side by side tripped
out didn't speak a word till hour like
seven or eight oh yeah pitch black
no no noise just the cars
on the street next to us
and some [ __ ] happened i talked about it
i never talked about everything there's
[ __ ] on story time i can't ever talk
about and i will never talk about but
the mushroom story time there was way
more than that astral projection people
keep saying
i'm gonna talk about it but there was a
lot more that happened i'll tell you
later a lot more that happened i saw
that i went
oh i'm about to crush it
oh this is too easy
like for life like oh this is what you
gotta do all right i'm gonna do all this
[ __ ] and even though when you come back
out of it goes away you forget about it
it's just
if you can open that part of your brain
go oh
okay i just reprogrammed my brain real
quick and that's all it is our brain's a
computer and it goes oh i have this
block on this level
oh let me just bypass that [ __ ] now i'm
on level 10.
that's all it is
it's very odd i gave marty nath didn't
even hit him
really yeah marty's made his fault his
brain strong to this full dab didn't
even touch him then he goes oh my
that dab should have smashed the shape
fat ass glob of hash frozen didn't even
affect him
well i appreciate it just depicted my
hands in a different way yeah but i'm
saying like [ __ ] eighth we gotta get
this full
oh i got the mushroom bars in my bag i
got you some mushrooms no i got some i
got some more i got some i got some
money yeah i was telling thomas like i
was just like hey i realized like i
haven't felt high in like [ __ ]
forever gave him a dab and he felt hot
but you want to do that i would say you
want to grind your mushrooms and then
put them in like some put them in like
get an orange and squeeze orange juice
in it
and take it like that sounds terrible oh
man
suggest you take these horrible
mushrooms that taste like [ __ ]
make it a powder what if you got the
capsule you just with the orange i gave
a bunch of cats
no no i gave them i gave my micro just
capsules that are ground up
point sevens okay so they're already
grinding yeah it's already done yeah
yeah i gave them already i know but i
mean it's best when you take them uh
take some uh you know squeeze like an
orange
so i'm a person that takes a lot of
emotions at once this [ __ ] will
go to regular places and eat mushrooms
i could see me being like that that's
how i am i know i know i have a lot of
homies that go to like [ __ ] business
meetings and take acid right before just
like i'm just feeling all open i'm open
you know i'm ready for ideas whoa
you guys are white white
all my white friends [ __ ] my ass so
heavy that it's insane
the psychedelics i don't give a [ __ ]
with anybody you know how people usually
go like these [ __ ] nerds and go all
the white dudes the ones with the fire
weed and you know not all white dudes
are nerds right it's not all a [ __ ]
chris rock skit you know life is not all
[ __ ] dangerous
[ __ ] nickel sacks yeah sure it's not
everybody's just oh
pleasantville what the [ __ ] i don't even
know those guys i never met one but
when it comes to psychedelics the white
guys are always the ones with the oh
yeah i lab test mine mine's just my
tester kit here's this they lay out a
pull fiction yeah exactly but it's
psychedelics you know how many times
i've seen that from professional looking
white dudes oh yeah today i blasted off
this morning what do you mean yeah like
i smoke dmt i'm trying to do 30 days of
you know like what
you're doing dmt every day for 30 days
to see how it affects you probably in a
bad way
[ __ ] but they'll always be like
professional white dudes that always
[ __ ] with the best drugs i feel like i
definitely have parts of my brain that
have not been unlocked marty's not there
yet marty's just smoked bam or weed in
the east coast came here spent fire just
tried shrooms didn't hit him he needs
fire yeah no actually i tried some uh
some white boy gave me some
some mv penis
[Laughter]
yo you can't say i met a white boy and
he gave me some envy penis
you can't say it like that
this shit's [ __ ] i met a white dude
and he gave me penis envy mushrooms
no they're called envy penis because it
kind of sounds like i made a white dude
he gave me angry penis
that sounds kind of stupid i'm not wrong
right that's what it sounds like i mean
if that's what you're into that's fine
nobody out there no we're not talking
[ __ ] but it's [ __ ] hilarious when you
say things like this to me
it's a strain of mushrooms called penis
envy yeah yeah they're [ __ ] i have
some
yeah and the white albinos
yeah those were good butters are cool i
don't really like it me [ __ ] i like
the mushroom i like that five gallons in
there the blue the blue strips i like
the blue stripes what are those called
like the cottage cheese no when you bite
them open it looks like
white i mean looks like uh blue like
stones like
what does that say like crystals
yeah i guess
it's just really kind of just all right
look at the ones have blue veins that
was the ones i like the blue ones
oh you're over you're throwing straight
away i'm asking you what the [ __ ] it
called i mean i thought i mean [ __ ] i
mean i got in some sort of vinyls and
they were purple too they were blue you
know what i mean then that's my machine
yeah i like the gold caps too okay but
when they're dry like when they're real
real dry i feel like the gold caps don't
touch me gold caps i like taking like
just the caps like [ __ ] maybe like a
one point one point five one point seven
this fool like does one to two grams you
know and then [ __ ] that goes to [ __ ]
dinner and [ __ ] so at that point is the
average man like seeing [ __ ] at that
point not all mushrooms make you
hallucinate some will just make you feel
in your body
like the coolest feeling you ever felt i
mean you're inflatable guys
yeah
i felt like that off somebody yeah it
depends you could i have i felt like
like i'm walking like i'm stretching
longer as i'm walking like this like the
ground's doing this oh [ __ ] yeah like if
you ran you'd be able to jump off the
ramp of the ground yeah we got to do the
three-on-three tournament like that
everybody oh my [ __ ] god
here mushroom oh gee marty
and thomas yeah i mean [ __ ] i haven't
had mushrooms i bought i want to say
it's been already it's been like a year
yeah yeah you haven't done it don't i
keep track of what you do every day
it's been 364 days
do you [ __ ] with dmt or any other
psychedelics you know what they gave me
some uh some frog skin
and oh you got the toad [ __ ] the meo5
whatever yeah
and uh i mean
to be honest did you do it no i didn't
do it you still have it in that thing i
remember you had it on yeah
you know i gave it to one of my friends
because he was shaving my ticket right
now you know and i go all right you want
to smoke it right here the caregiver
somebody needed it he felt it
he was scared to take it no no it wasn't
i was scared but it's just
fear
i didn't trust the guy to watch me you
know what i mean
yeah [ __ ] that yeah i mean so i i
started you know you wake up and you
have no pain
no money left no i actually gave it at
first i started off like you're going to
give me this much right here and then i
go you know what smoking right now you
give me this much for it you forced sold
it to him well i mean because he wanted
it he was bugging free like you know
what
yeah
come on
you know
you're giving me thirty two dollars
yeah
this piece of animal skin yeah that's
what the gang banger was trying to do to
him at the shop
yeah no
you want to give me this for 25 right
you know where i'm from
america yeah yeah
that's someone says you know where i'm
from
america
[ __ ] yeah but you know what street
no
just keep walking i had a foreign dude
press me and that's what i said i said
are you serious or in here yeah you got
a
foreign stop yeah did you tell it on the
podcast did you tell me yeah i told it
also everyone knows what you just said
to lie
he didn't press you pressed your wife
and you scared him death yeah
inadvertently yeah he didn't say
he said told me go said go back to where
you come from type of [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh yeah it's right that's right
he said do the white guy with blue eyes
go back where you come from you
english-speaking [ __ ]
with a fake accent in socal
and you ask why do go back to where you
came from costa mesa
go back to your hometown if you would
have said that go back to whatever town
you came from would have been made but
the dude was not [ __ ] born i've had
fat guys call me fat and that's funny
too
i've had real fat dudes call me fat [ __ ]
and it's like
you're [ __ ] kidding me right now
it's like the raider fans beating up
raider fans at [ __ ] the game the
other day
so you guys [ __ ] kidding me actually
we haven't seen them there you know we
didn't even see yeah because i told you
hey i ain't going in there i'm going
back to the phone it's going to get high
remember you guys were like yo let's
walk in the tailgate i went i'll wait
here i was actually surprised you did go
walk in there i didn't leave i didn't
think you were gonna even do that i only
wanted it was like
from we were 30 seconds to the next four
seconds this guy just [ __ ]
i was shocked well because everybody was
leaving like [ __ ] all right hurry up
let's go yeah i'm like we're gonna go
and this was like i ain't going i'm cool
i'm like
[ __ ]
i stand by the side while everybody
fights
they're good bro and then they go back
to their mom's house
i'm just talking [ __ ] because i don't
like the great i'm a [ __ ] packer fan
[ __ ] tucking this [ __ ] in there no
the raiders are bored my second favorite
team growing up my whole life i'm pretty
sure the packers and the raiders that's
who i loved the raiders were the [ __ ]
when i was a kid didn't they used to
like they used to make you wear a jersey
jersey no i wore them to the game so i
would get my ass whooped as a child
because my dad's uh my dad's brother my
uncle his friends old bulldog travel i
don't know if you from from merced
remember bulldog travel the two dudes
that used to take the huge via bus and
take everybody to raider games i used to
go to radio games every weekend with my
dad
well not every weekend as a kid you
think it's everything it's probably
every couple months
i went to
i've been to about four raider games
with my dead women exaggerated
[ __ ] i didn't give you no credit
you were not there that much i went
about four or five radio games with my
dad all right but that's a lot that's
more than none oh yeah right but i'm
over here saying like all the time what
a dummy i've been about five games but
we get on the bus we'd stop at casa de
fruit and mexican restaurant and then
we'd go to the [ __ ] game from merced
oh fresno go up uh 152 stop there and
then we'd leave
or maybe it's cause different anyway
i've been to so many raider games and i
would put on a jersey just to not get my
ass whooped
it's ruthless at the raider of the
oakland games
oh it's [ __ ] ruthless if you wear any
other jersey i don't care what age you
are you might get something thrown at
you even as a child oh yeah you might be
in a stroller and still get something
[ __ ] thrown your way
do you think i'm kidding
you think i'm lying i'm not [ __ ]
lying
i've seen a [ __ ] four-year-old kid
remember i told you the end of the story
you [ __ ] i won't i can't even say it
but she called him the f word and it was
a a homosexual uh downing term
she called the little tiny boy in the
niner jersey
and she said i went oh
she drew her eyebrows on and then came
to the [ __ ] game and called a little
boy this
he was a little [ __ ] boy and the dad
didn't do [ __ ] which is more like damn
full i always talk to [ __ ] in the mouth
for calling my son that
i don't care if it's a girl you're going
the [ __ ] down for calling my little baby
that
you know right you have to for your girl
like i might spit in your face yeah
something has to happen i can't let you
go on the rest of the day thinking that
you're okay
anyway that's the raider games for me
that's why i don't go to the raider
games and when you said let's go i went
no you were down all right let's go yeah
let's go [ __ ] yeah when i picked them
before i picked them up i got all this
[ __ ] i told my girl you know what it's
[ __ ] right when he picks me up and he
goes i'm surprised i bet you all night
you're thinking why am i going with og
that's exactly what i was actually just
thinking
why am i even going with this guy this
fool's a mess
we've talked about you the smokey weed
in the 7-eleven now imagine that the
only reason he didn't light up joints in
the seats and get us kicked out is
because they took his ladder away he
took my [ __ ] ladder
they took his lighter away as we walked
into he had his weak it took his lighter
when he goes
security oh yeah because he can't take
the ladder in
and he i know
he would write that to the metal
detection he would light it he would
light it up
no matter if there was a i'm like there
was no kids by us well i wouldn't hit it
because there was no kids but that could
have been and that's why i was like
he was asking the lighter you got a
lighter when you guys were gone to the
bathroom
lighter [ __ ] city over here
and nobody had one
nobody had one but he would have lit up
and got us kicked the [ __ ] out he can't
bring a lighter into a stadium no but he
[ __ ] weed oh cause he had weed they
wouldn't let him have his life no they
just take your lighter because you can't
lighters okay
just you just can't bring a lighter into
a game because somebody might be in the
bathroom just starting a [ __ ] fire
which is reasonable to think you know
people are weird well that's not right
i mean there's a lot of people
there
tickets
yeah i should just keep my line in my
pocket and went through a metal detector
[ __ ] it wouldn't it went off you know
yeah what if there's metal on it
no it's just a little bit of metal he
says like a bullet size
for sure you know it's like a
yeah i was trying to explain to marty i
saw this thing on tick tock the other
day and people were like yo this guy
needs an award and they go this guy
needs to
say who he learned that from because
that's an old trick this kid went to
coachella and went the week before and
went to a tree that's in the side of the
ring or the
arena
wherever they put the coachella because
outdoor and he buried hella bottles of
taco vodka or vodka so you can dig them
up during the concert like oh [ __ ] i got
two bottles i have to pay for whoa right
but people just used to do that with
their guns
oh yeah they never do that here
okay cool i was trying to explain to him
like merced there was hella shootings at
the fair there's someone always gets
hurt at the fair because
apparently a family time is where gang
bangers need to fight it out
i go to the fair in the week i never go
on fridays or saturdays because that's
when people get shot it's because myself
in the 90s right now i know but that's
what i'm saying it's an old school trick
i used to remember the gangsters every
time the games bangers would like walk
by the fence go oh
damn
i gotta have time to leave
parties [ __ ] like oh deebo's here that's
how i felt like [ __ ] let's go i'm done
looking at the world's biggest pig
anyway i'm out of the fair [ __ ] this
that pig was huge though he doesn't know
which one i'm talking about you guys
have seen the biggest pig and
they just buried their guns or their
knives right by the tree line you know
inside the state in the arena the fair
and then when you see the fools you
don't like because they got a different
color on that you grew up with
you know you go get the gun and kill
them at the fair how many people died or
got shot merced [ __ ] county fair
should google that [ __ ] how many people
have gone
i think i was in sixth grade when they
used to hit metal detectors all over the
sides of the trees when the fair started
because at night you just hop the fence
bury your gun and leave in case you need
to [ __ ] shoot someone at the fair
stupid [ __ ] god i hate that [ __ ] so
much anyway that's an old school trick
yeah you just bury your knife or your
[ __ ] i mean i've done that man like
burying your guns yeah you bear your gun
on in like in the dirt under the girt so
when you come into the fair you oh i've
got nothing on me and you walk by where
you buried it you get your gun back well
i mean usually back then we would just
give it to the girl and the girl would
just put it but they're metal detecting
up over here merced they wand you go
through them
they're doing 90s
it's not as bad i bet you it's not as
bad is it bad rosie still at the fair
so here we go nevermind there was a
shooting this this
so everybody's waiting for this fair
no no because everybody wants to go to
the fair because they want to take their
[ __ ] girlfriend out and they get
murdered but [ __ ] bro you gotta go to
the ferry and i need your goodness so
when you do go to the fair you have a
gun
yeah
there's some [ __ ] i remember my
homies i had little knives
i just i used to hide weed and i'm not
even lying i did it i did it one [ __ ]
fair when i used to live but i lived by
the fair on sixth street i've hit my
weed there once but i didn't i put it in
a bush i didn't bury it like a [ __ ]
aztec
or whatever [ __ ]
guys that do stuff i don't know i didn't
go to school like oh gee man
all right
i didn't go to school we don't know
geography or [ __ ] history
i'm gonna call you almost
almost ever seen apocalypto yes yeah you
have yeah is it because mel gibson
filmed it
[ __ ] no i don't know because you ain't
never seen [ __ ] no it was just random
that i saw that [ __ ] what a good movie
yeah i remember the scene where they oh
that was [ __ ] up you know what i do
turn around look like
yeah right there i'm gonna stay you
almost stand here
i guess
right
you know what else they're doing i would
try to kill the man that makes me run to
a field of spears
like i'm gonna die out there i might as
well die with my thumbs in your eyes
i mean it's easy to say i guess i get it
i ain't going out like that
i'm not fast
i'll do the [ __ ] baby d [ __ ] on
friday too
and okay first beer i'm [ __ ] gone
seven yards in
dead
i know my chance i'll live and only
catch me in the back of my leg and i'll
[ __ ] die in the woods
hey back to apocalypto man that movie
was crazy
there's only a movie ever watching my
grandpa greg
because he's a [ __ ] apocalypto menace
we probably grew up with those [ __ ]
people it was crazy the crap was crazy
um
what the [ __ ] are we talking about
we see this the podcast is everywhere
let's take another shot one more one
more well 135 we're not bad we're doing
good this cricket's going strong yeah
yes yes
he hasn't stopped by the way og actually
googled it first time everything seemed
you actually try to help me
and it's mating season
for [ __ ] grasshoppers it's like it's
a [ __ ] full moon yeah it's a full
moon it's about 82 degrees it's
grasshopper [ __ ] season so
that's what's going on guys last episode
of the season might as well as a train a
[ __ ] plane
there's a cricket going on
the sign fell off and we had to stick it
back up before it might fall off i hope
right when we stop and go all right
thanks guys bob sign falls off and goes
you know it is the end of the season
truly because this [ __ ] fell three
times in the past three weeks it's just
asking us to leave
yeah it's like you guys know what it's
time to [ __ ] go and that's what it's
telling us it's [ __ ] right it's ready
to go uh-huh all right one more shot one
more shot oga a plethora of questions
hey you ever seen uh three amigos yeah
he's a sweater
uncle john you should say that [ __ ] all
the time it makes me laugh oh you're
good huh i'm sure
you say chevy chase are you saying you
need a chase
oh yeah
that [ __ ] funny
is you ready
thanks last episode of the season
bowl
ready serious question coming up
and you don't get second chance you have
to answer it once you can't go no no no
no no you have to think and then say
your answer
are you ready
american me or blow in and blood out
if you had to pick one forever oh of
course american oh of course he says
really
it's too much
did you say bloody blood out blood and
blood out or sorry sorry sorry what do
you call it justin what do you call
blood and blood out
bound by honor he will not say blood and
blood that's the subtitle
and this full calls it's like saying
batman return or for forever before what
does it say like but you know yeah
before it was i think they did call the
bomber for a minute and it was back too
but um
oh i did it i had the teeth i just
thought bloody blood out just a little
bit you didn't like it
what the [ __ ] what did you like about it
[Music]
but i mean
i think
i don't know i just it just didn't it
was just a little kind of a little i
don't know my thinking the way i think i
thought just a little more i know i want
to know what you think
all right i mean it's cool i liked it
but i just didn't think it would i
thought i just think about american me
was a lot more more realistic more you
know
even though like some parts yeah a lot
of [ __ ] doesn't happen but i just
thought maybe it was more realistic
except they made [ __ ] up
well no it was not that well it's a
movie you know i mean of course they're
gonna put [ __ ] in there it was supposed
to be a real story though i mean how
many crazy ass white boy [ __ ] psychos
with the
you know they like i said they based
their character for [ __ ] me myself
and irene off that dude to see him like
oh gee probably didn't what the [ __ ] are
you talking about i'm talking about the
[ __ ] blood and blood out you seen it
right am i talking about the right
[ __ ] movie no
yeah with the white dude who's all crazy
he's got they're driving around i'm
probably talking about the wrong though
that is the right movie you've seen this
movie you put me onto it yeah you're the
one that so wait yeah why did you bring
up jim gary because that dude you know
myself and irene took the whole
dude's persona
nah this is the wrong movie
what it was it was
the guy the white guy in the movie is
mexican
blood and blood but he speaks spanish
yeah but he's mexican and he's half
white uh-huh
well but he's a full white dude though
right no he's he's no that's harsh times
that's christian bale in harsh times
fully me myself when i'm in psychotic
[ __ ]
you ever seen harsh times which
christian bale about the cops in esla
companies late
[ __ ] harsh times yeah
that's who he's talking about
okay now we're talking about blood and
blood out is uh you know what it is
it's different it's a gangnam
benjamin bratt he banged julia roberts
you can't ask for the same caliber of
acting exactly so that's just what i say
i'd rather go okay i can see that you
know what's crazy to me though is the
fact they had a white guy in the mexican
mafia and also shang lao or whatever
from mortal kombat asian
in the mexican mafia you couldn't tell
me that was realistic
what do you mean what do i mean in
america me his right hand man was an
asian his other one was white yeah and
the mexican mafia leader and he gets to
have other friends [ __ ]
but it was more realistic
i think it was more realistic you think
that's realistic i mean is that a real
story for reals yeah it was an asian and
white person well i'm not i don't know
the asian i'm pretty sure there's
there's been asians and i'm pretty sure
don't be saying pretty soon oh wow i'm
pretty sure there is you know what i
mean the leader that makes me want to
get that the movie's about down the line
there's one that's been you know yeah
like just so you're saying i'm pretty
sure down the line
mafia had an asian america the white boy
that's in that character that way that's
a real guy yes it's a real guy that's a
real dude yes okay and the asian guy and
the asian guy you know i'm not too sure
i'm not gonna say
if the white guy's true
i'm fine with it there's like a ginger
mexican
no no this month what was his name
william william forsyth who was right he
passed away already yeah you know joe
morgan that's who's supposed to be i
believe the guy in the american me
that's what they were oh you're talking
about the real guy's name yeah oh i'm
talking about william forsythe the actor
yeah sorry i only know actors names
william force hey
yeah no that's what i mean you could you
could look them up and [ __ ] boy four
side's a bad eye you look him up
he's a great actor he was more a little
more realistic but i get it no
everything in it was [ __ ] that's fine
i didn't know there was a real white
dude mafia that makes it so much [ __ ]
better
but
you want to hear something crazy for all
you [ __ ] out there that have
seen american me you know what this
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] did to me the
other day
i answered the [ __ ] i answered his call
on facetime he had his phone down and he
had no wall in front he just does this
that's it
what movies that go
that's horrible whatever you're trying
to tell me i bet you it's not even that
and the end of american me when the
grandpa looks at his grandkid leave the
house and he puts his hand on the wall
and goes
and looks at his [ __ ] tattoo and he
goes
that's what he was impersonating what a
piece of [ __ ] i said i wouldn't be
surprised of course i didn't guess it he
just did this if he would have went
against a wall i would have been like
grandpa from america me looking at his
tattoo all right i get it but no he just
mimed it and did this that's because
homeboy had a [ __ ] cross and three
dies and at the end i'm not sure what is
it is it was it justin
justin does not have three dots that
would not be my homie a cross and three
dots he does not have that don't say
that someone does remember none of my
[ __ ] friends have a three dollar oh
[ __ ] look at this guy none of my oh omar
thank you one more but it's not three
dots it's like seven it's a part of his
tattoo
don't be calling my friends a [ __ ]
gangbanger
it's a cross on his hands they're
praying it's for jesus
he's trying to set omar up he's on tour
man he's still gonna go down south don't
be saying that [ __ ] i don't know
none of my friends have gangster tattoos
bro
i know better because if i get pulled
over they're going to go
who's this guy now that was his
impersonation he just does this
that's exactly what you did i have a
very good memory sir
i'm not tripping yeah you are i'm
definitely not hold on more to it it was
not there was not for sure it was not
did you
no
so american me is very good it's really
good blood and blood out so i always say
american me
godfather
american me godfather in it blood and
blood out good
i
fellas
if you have to compare them oh
the way how it's a godfather's mad crazy
serious and super cinematic and you know
those [ __ ] 10 minute scenes of
dialogue when goodfellas like you know
when i wanted to be a gangster he's
[ __ ] stabbing a fool and shooting him
in the trunk and blood and blood out
he's just doing
this [ __ ] with [ __ ] first six
seconds in
bro i love that movie but the way miklo
[ __ ] slaps his chest so [ __ ] hard
when he gets off the [ __ ] car to go
back to east l.a makes me laugh every
time
every time it's like cuba goodings
that's the comparison like yo why'd you
slap your chest so hard it always made
me feel weird like he [ __ ] hit
himself to throw up his own gang to the
sky
he was with nobody in that scene he
wasn't with anybody when he pulled up
and he seen the the tree
the tree right yeah i know but i don't
see trees and [ __ ] throw up gang
signs in nature well i mean that's just
something he's just banged on nature no
he's just his hood he banged on that
it's just good all right you know what
i'm gonna start anybody for me i'm
pretty sure i'm gonna start doing that
every time i go back to recently like
that
yeah for sure something thumbs up
you know at the biggest tree i see like
jeez for sure that's the one number one
thing they'll do i get it they get out
they pull up to the hood and they're
throwing they throw a gang sign up
because they're totally difficult
oh to the lord i [ __ ] with that i like
that better you know that guy that says
jesus christ on the line yeah that max
can do with it's all tatted and jesus
christ he's from her set
he's from merced well he is yes and
people always send me oh it's your homie
from shame on the show but what
that motherfucker's wild i mean in a
good way he's a
for god
he looks like a gangster but he only
preaches and he's like a preacher
but he has jesus christ tatted on his
face sure all right no like this is the
best thing he could have did like he's
actually making it like nothing you're
allowed to have faith even if you look
like me it's like all right i like it
but people are like yo you're from
yourself like bro that is not my uncle
yeah i'm not really people go oh is this
your uncle from mercedes shut up well he
says his mercedes so damn small i'm like
yeah [ __ ] you i get it but you think i
wouldn't have been like yo my uncle's
this wild ass preacher he's cr you know
i just got a haircut eight seconds
before this started and he put the
alcohol on my [ __ ] it really grew back
i got alcohol and the sweat from these
headphones just made me uh
gonna sting
like some peroxide just went across the
cut
because the [ __ ] alcohol just mixed i
just felt it oh [ __ ] anyway so american
meat be that wire
it's not the wire
it's not it's not even on that side man
well i mean it's part of it's going this
way hey so you're picking american me
good fellas
oh yeah and then i started talking about
miklo throwing his gang sign up hard and
then he says fools do that
all right i'll take it back i mean i've
seen it it's a realistic scene i've seen
some
people do that yeah it's not is that you
i've seen [ __ ] it's nothing new
get out of the car
yeah you start gaming
yo i wish
gang bangers only shot at other gang
bangers because then i'd hang out with
them more
because i don't want to get shot up just
because i'm with somebody that's why i
stopped hanging out with certain people
and personally bro
i'm gonna get hot just hanging out with
you about who's your friend like you
mean the kid with a slick hair and like
looks super nice oh he's so sweet
[ __ ]
yeah i mean i can't ever get away with
it i can't ever be okay because the guy
undercover with all the weed
yeah exactly
he looks like one and people are going
to assume you are one i can't hang out
with those guys guilty by association
man i have cousins that i didn't even
associate with in school i say what up
what's up full but i wouldn't go hang
out with evils
all my cousins used to carry around the
cerano card remember when you got busted
enough you have to carry around the gang
card they do that down here what do you
mean
damn they didn't do that
what the little card
no a card with what gang you are with
your picture and everything
you never have to do that here no bro
where i'm from if you get busted enough
and you're underage if you get in
trouble enough and associated with the
gang they make you carry around a card
if you don't have your card you go
automatically to jail
carry around south side sereno what gang
you're from what street you're from who
you associate with your nicknames and
your picture oh [ __ ] my cousins all my
cousins i don't say their names i had
three cousins that were so they all had
to carry their car it's like a gang
banging trading card you kind of it's
like you yeah it's like a [ __ ] tops
yeah it's got your stats no for real for
real like your arrest record and all
that [ __ ] was on it's like a [ __ ]
baseball card you're right but my
cousins
were they weren't as clo we played
football with them on thanksgivings like
those because you'll see a lot a lot but
you see them you know sometimes you'll
see them in town like what's up
you know those cousins they're born he's
born three days later than me and has
older brothers they're cool now they're
all like what do you think they do what
do you think old gang bangers did in
school mexican fools that don't gang
bang anymore what job do they do here's
a game
what do you think he does not
construction something else because
that's too easy what do you think this
mexican gang maker of my cousin does now
that used to be a hardcore gangbanger
kid
[ __ ] i wanna say maybe uh
come on i think you're gonna guess it
there's only a few things that get old
gangbangers dudes do now
come on
when he does tattoos no come on well not
that's the kind of gang related
what regular job does my cousin have now
what you know when you see old fools all
right you ever see the guy in the line
at wendy's you know caltrans
not that not a construction type of
dudes exactly that's what every old game
maker works at they all so don't fight
the guys at the store that learn work
[ __ ] they all are covered in prison tats
underneath just let you know
what regular job does he do now that all
[ __ ] gang makers get into if it's not
[ __ ] construction come on we know
this
usually
people work the docks and the freight
line and [ __ ] i know oh you're in la
there's no document set i'm gonna make
this easier for you he's a air
conditioned technician oh [ __ ]
everybody goes into electrical [ __ ]
everybody that either was a gang banger
or a tweaker now works with electronics
and you know that's true and they're
always kind of dirty
that job whatever job consists you be
kind of dirty but you're working with
electronic electrical [ __ ] on the poles
it's something always have to do
something with that that's my cousin
does now oh i know i brought that up but
it's so funny to see him in high school
go i hope you don't die [ __ ] we
just had that oh he's gotta he's got
another job he's got another kid
good job man
it's crazy for me to see my cousins now
one of them's uh
my cousin that had to carry around the
car the one that got the first card
that [ __ ] is i think is a uh
corrections
dude that talks to the youth
he's the guy at the correctional [ __ ]
that comes to fools on their first term
and he like tries to correct them in
jail so my cousin went from being that
[ __ ] cereal kid i remember i would
not associate with these fools outside
of [ __ ] grandma's [ __ ]
thanksgiving play football other than
that like
keep stepping this way man i ain't
trying to be involved with anything you
got going on i saw my cousin fighting
this huge dude went
i'm not helping you out you got 12
gangbanger homies with you i am not
trying to be like yo that's that fool
that was trying to fight you you know
what i'm saying hey that's that fat kid
oh who's selling weed i walk in with a
pack
hey that's the fool that [ __ ] jumped
me with those gang makers at school
that's you know what i'm saying it's a
small town it's gonna happen that's how
you get jumped again if it's a small
town so basically you just feel like you
lived in a small neighborhood which was
just one small neighborhood that one
gang no no merced is like as big as esla
it's it's only 80 000 people though
but when i was younger
everybody was just
before social media
social media made everybody go in their
house
and gay marriage talk [ __ ] online before
you had to get stabbed and [ __ ] we're
talking [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
but merced is 20 years behind earth
you know what i'm saying like we get
people are just getting on like the game
which i'm just kidding but
fools are 20 years behind fools are
still gaming and asking where you're
from and we're set
regular kids they're shooting the
college kids outside of [ __ ]
victoria's tacos two years ago two white
kid college kids got shot in the [ __ ]
legs these fools just going around just
going around psalms
popped him in the leg and just kept
driving just to [ __ ] around but it
happened two weekends in a row in the
same corner so obviously they were
initiating these little kids i'm like yo
you got to shoot somebody yeah i see
those those those
that's generation
but that's merced still i got shot in
the back of that you know i told you
whenever i got shot in the back of the
head but i [ __ ] homemade gun
remember that little [ __ ] little
bastard
and i'm like nope i ain't turned around
good thing i didn't hit me in the teeth
but yeah that full [ __ ] popped me
with a little shotgun a little bastard
we talked about it have we talked about
it right here yeah told me once about it
yeah some [ __ ] like that
if it was a real gonna be dead
i mean thank god he just missed you no
he hit me directly
no you mean tell me he shot you with a
bullet no the big steelies
he made a potato gun full uh-huh what do
you hit you with he hit me with a bunch
of train steelies the ones at the
[ __ ] tracks the railroad tracks
yeah i got shot with a musket bro this
dip you see this dip that's from that
and the one on top is from the toy chest
my mom i talked about it that's the toy
chest and this is the little bastard
that tried to shoot me in the head well
that did shoot me in the head well look
how deep my finger goes yeah yeah he got
me good it dented my head i still [ __ ]
you i was pissed i should have went to
the doctor but i definitely felt a crack
so for sure i did have headaches for
months after [ __ ] headaches yeah yeah
probably bro i did it was some [ __ ]
but but you know people get that's crazy
mercedes crazy but we are on the night
we're in like year 2004 now merced fools
are like
not wearing all red big big tall tees
and
you don't wear blue talties there but
nobody's wearing red tall tees and red
checkered shirts anymore
you know what i'm saying like it's it's
changing to where
uh are too
interested on making money on snapchat
and selling packs you know what teaches
what's teaching everybody now is this
internet right
yeah it's it's it's good though yeah
it's good it's making people be
kind of big kind of just yeah it puts
everybody on the same page yeah it's
kind of like it's kind of better but
we're trying to make money yeah i don't
want to fight i don't want to shoot out
with you for you how much money you're
making on snap how much money i'm making
selling xanax to somebody like
i think there's too much money to shoot
each other right now
that's how i feel
i had this shirt
uh
and i gotta make it now i had this shirt
and it's a logo it says less clapping
more trapping
like you know and it says stop the
violence it's a push trees logo i made
it less traffic less clapping more
traffic
and it's true there's too much money to
be shooting each other it's just crazy
like when kovid was going on i saw
nobody getting shot
for like what two months there was no
rapper's day dying at all
and then [ __ ] started getting
popped again but it's crazy we all got
scared during covert like you know the
earth might end and i'm over here buying
a designer watch or a [ __ ] nice hat
and i can't even find food right now and
really put [ __ ] in perspective and then
people like oh it's
it's not as crazy oh we can go outside
i'm gonna go shoot that
you know they [ __ ] [ __ ]
pandemic about it and there we are
but i'm saying like for a while people
weren't going crazy because nobody was
outside
yeah for sure
so it for a second it did die down yeah
it did but i remember seeing people get
shot like people my homies posting like
rp [ __ ] like damn phil got popped during
kovid
you're out there
too you know what i mean yeah yeah
people getting robbed all at all time
how you see melrose right now fools
getting snatched up in the day bro
melrose really like [ __ ] all i know is
you got to stop trying to rob people
with big chains because you think those
fools are going to blast too you're
tripping
you how many people are getting blasted
right now trying to steal [ __ ] a lot
during coven when that when that riot
happened when all the riots were
happening up north and all the legal
distributors got robbed you see that you
see that for sure dude a lot of people
died i know a lot of fools that work up
there it wasn't in the news like 15
people died that night up in those up in
the in oakland
a lot of people are getting desperate
now they're getting desperate like i'm
gonna go rob the dispensary
full they got armed security that's
gonna kill you
and they got killed
a lot of people got killed which is
crazy bro people are going nuts
for sure uh so uh american me all right
let's wrap it over there yeah we wrapped
it all i don't know where we went with
that
are you ready
i know i don't know if we could talk
about it so i want to ask you can you
tell me about
can you tell me about the time you
almost died making
chatter oh [ __ ] when the [ __ ] yes
yeah hold on just say it explain the
story this is a storytelling audience
don't be pulp fictioning us and giving
us the end
by the way the boring [ __ ] first
machine
you know talking to the microphone you
know sorry start it over yeah dude
that's my boss right now you know i mean
i was running one of those machines but
before you know before i i started
working for him you know okay stop
hey what's up guys thank you so much for
watching this mid roll ad read this is
coming from one of our long time
sponsors on it real quick let me tell
you a little story on it sells creatine
creatine is actually really good for
muscle building i know that because of
this little story when i was in the
fourth grade i started playing football
and my dad took it upon himself to take
me to gnc and get me creatine when i was
a kid little did i know creatine makes
you get buff and put on weight but not
if you're not active and you're just a
fourth grader that plays football
it didn't work on me all right so when i
got older i went nah creatine don't work
and they went no but you're supposed to
exercise so that's why i know what
creatine is i just i just was a fat kid
so if you're a full grown adult and you
actually know how to use creatine and
you want to go to the store and get it
don't stop right now go on your phone go
on your computer go to onit.com that's
onnit.com forward slash yola and that's
gonna get you 10 off the entire store
except for the weights all the
nutritional powders all the pills all
the vitamins every single thing all the
gear everything but the weights as i
said before anna is not about just
getting buff and flexing on your friends
this is human optimization okay like i
said before this is for your brain down
to your feet there's shroom tech gut
health there's new mood there's alpha
brain like i said yes there's creatine
there's a whey protein there's powders
there's all that stuff but like i said
your brain is a big muscle in your body
too you should take care of it they have
the gut health of digest tech that's for
everything your digestion will track the
strong immune system that's with the
shroom tech the stuff for your brain for
the mood and relaxation that's the new
mood on it has their own coffee mct oil
and as i said before they have their own
gear and they have awesome designs you
guys got to check them out it's all
very
spiritual psychedelic ape based that's
how me marty always put it it's some
cool it's cool and yes they have regular
clothes that just say on it they're not
so loud like where to the gym but they
do have like i said some of the designs
are awesome if you have any interest
whatsoever to better your health better
anything about your body human
optimization if this interests you at
all go to onit.com that's o-n-n-i-t dot
com that's on it.com forward slash yola
and that's 10 off your entire order
thank you guys so much for watching
shout out to onit back to the episode
oh just come around i would work oh she
used to make shadow you have to explain
it you make shadows and help them out
making the shadow and i'll go there
and you know
so they would leave me there you know
take care of this watch this
oh my god you're the worst bro hold on
you can die you have to explain why it's
scary well i mean these machines can
blow up and kill you
you ever seen in the audience or people
in the audience it was the [ __ ] in
the news it wasn't like a homemade
machine it was like it's a legit machine
but you could still die with a
closed-loop system yeah exactly hold on
explain to the audience when you make
shatter with butane you have to explain
it because some people like what do you
mean you almost died you can die making
shatter in an enclosed room if you have
a dog running around while you're making
chatter that static electricity could
spark off the gas that's leaking you
blow up
you dragging your feet you on your phone
that's what i want to have
we had a rug we had this we had this
outside
it was it wasn't still we didn't have in
the right tub i mean this was [ __ ]
years back you're trapping it out
looking in the right proper room but
dude i know that i heard i heard that
little
static
you're a horrible storyteller no
there's a knob on the bottom of the
machine that releases the valve of the
gas you have to tell people what's
happening well i mean [ __ ] well say
there's a valve in the bottom machine on
the bottom machine i started hearing it
and it'll be
when the gas starts leaking at an
abnormal rate a beeping will start going
off baby baby a big alarm let no get the
[ __ ] out the room
for sure so one time og almost died and
i'll explain the [ __ ] story okay i
heard the spray bro so what i had to do
is i had to get a i had to get a um a
little red i had to get a wrench and
close it back up because obviously the
[ __ ] hose is leaking and it's
spraying out crazy i have one foot on
top of the rug and i'm saying there we
go [ __ ] this [ __ ] can cause some static
right here they should sprain so
immediately bro i [ __ ] you know bro i
seriously bro i [ __ ] put my head up
against this [ __ ] and i just
closed it right there so if i'm [ __ ]
gonna blow up bro i'm [ __ ] gonna blow
up i don't want to be
no i'm not getting your hand blown off
yeah i don't want to be you know [ __ ]
in the hospital so i [ __ ] literally
put my head up against it and i turned
off the yeah i was just thinking [ __ ]
this is it like you better [ __ ] make
sure this [ __ ] closes and i did close it
but dude that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
about halfway through that story you
started getting a good storyteller man
the first half was dog [ __ ] man what it
what just clothes
i thought i was done bro i go show this
[ __ ] sticking out and i realized that
i'm on top of a map of a rug so i'm
saying well this shit's good you know
all of a sudden i started spraying i'm
like no it's not cool now i'm [ __ ]
even one piece of static electricity
sparks that entire room and the tank
[ __ ] thing
just explodes it gives you people's
house explode the news yeah like they
said about merced
that's almost happened to this guy
happened to my brother right next door
there's got to be a better [ __ ] way
jesus christ yeah it's called hash
make rosin squish it no chemicals
but they're doing butane system and a
lot of people do it open blast where
they just press it through their hands
with the big tubes and then their homies
smoking a [ __ ] blow on the other side
of the house and it catches everything
you don't die that way but you get
[ __ ] up yeah so i mean [ __ ]
like i said this was this was one of my
my friends that was still into making
shannon you know what i mean so [ __ ]
back then they were like [ __ ] it i'm
gonna try it i'm gonna work it for you
i'll do it so
started doing it and
[ __ ] i mean it worked out for a while
you know what i mean but [ __ ] bro after
a while it was [ __ ] pretty dangerous
well he almost died yeah it sounds like
you know but that leak is what happens
before it blows up
that's what happened it [ __ ] up
the machine malfunction you're about to
die
that's scary [ __ ] i have a homie that
has a facility that has well it was it
wasn't the machine wasn't a jib machine
you know i mean it was such a gas
machine it was like set up pretty proper
but the only thing it didn't have like
uh it didn't have ventilation at all
certain [ __ ] didn't happen
just trapping it out
yeah he bought the really nice machine
and put it in a [ __ ] house basically
and didn't get a ventilation system oh
no it wasn't in the house no there was
no ventilation system
the gas out
yeah well you know back then the
regulations didn't come in until after i
know i'm still on you didn't have the
system back then it was still
prop 215 it was still legal to do it but
[ __ ] now hell no they got all these
regulations where yeah you're safer now
you know yeah the rule
back then you weren't safe bro it was
like it was like there was a regulation
for burley coming in you it's like
before having car jacks and you had to
change the tire at a shop it's like yo
yo let's stack it with bricks yeah or
however they did it it's like yeah it'll
work but dude it'd be so much safer we
had a lift
not having a [ __ ] air vent is not
having a lift yeah and like i said i
have a homie that has one you only have
10 seconds before you pass out but if it
blows up it will suck that explosion
into a [ __ ] vent and it's like on top
of the top of the line [ __ ] he spent so
much money on it but it sucks the air
out so the fire dissipates
but you also suffocate
so you have 10 seconds to gather room it
was it was you know it was yeah it was
the chicken
[ __ ] back there
it wasn't legit
yeah he was using a nice machine not
hooked up to the [ __ ] that's regulated
now
that's all he was using a [ __ ]
wrecking ball with no [ __ ] permit is
what was going on yeah
yeah so that's the time you almost died
for real [ __ ] i nearly thought i was bro
yeah i know
that's why literally i just [ __ ] put
my head up against it oh i'm done here
you know i mean [ __ ]
that's scary it turned out good you know
i mean [ __ ] it was actually pretty fun
out there it was not pretty fun after oh
that doesn't say that
i mean [ __ ] yeah you know i mean just
bro you bought an entire bag of weed
[ __ ] we haven't even opened it
open it up
it'd be all right
no not that
you brought a whole bag of weed [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i said you said [ __ ] all
right
yeah what do you confuse that with what
do you think i said
you brought a whole bag you brought a
whole bag of weed that's great
i was like no it didn't bring no bag
away let's just grab the bag
you want to pull everything out yeah
sure what he brought yeah
just some different [ __ ] bro different
[ __ ] they give me about the whole day
bro you know
vendors come in and out they give me all
kinds of [ __ ] hella tripping on
ourselves
and
stuff like that you know cool in this
past event we were up there what is this
thc shots
this is the whole tincture you want to
try i dare you to drink it after this
tincture bottle oh okay come on you'll
be fine what is it how many a thousand
bro how does it not say it it doesn't
say the milligrams on it
how are they gonna do that to somebody
i don't even know it doesn't say [ __ ]
milligrams that's amazing
what else you got here boy
hey you want some gummies
sure
look at that throw oh it's a trash
though
hey open these up what's up let's use
some medicals boys it's my favorite for
you
hey get out of here man
i know you're like
get out of here
hey you guys ever seen spawn
do you remember the clown john loganzano
in the cloud
what's up g playing them
remember
you paid 30 bucks for that roll
here we go
next question
jesus christ sorry
i just
hey you ever seen somebody's life
yeah how
can more edibles no for real
oh hold on hold on hold on
always
stop i have a question
same question
don't be a shitty storyteller on this
one
with some stories that damn bro you
gotta be descriptive
can you tell us about
the super super super strong edibles
used to make in the early 2000s that you
gave your homies dad and then he died oh
you son of a [ __ ] this [ __ ]
he gave his homies edibles and then he
[ __ ] died [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] and i'm saying we kills
people all right
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
no names i didn't say i said you're
homie
but say given the circumstances it's not
like he was just a healthy man
but the man died off og's [ __ ]
edibles
and not saying we kills him you'll see
the circumstances go oh
best death ever no no
my boy was making me yo can you speak in
your microphone this guy was one of my
boys who made these they were actually
um you said you made them hmm i started
making oh wait you're right we had to
cut them down you're right you did tell
me yeah after someone died you started
making them less potent i remember that
yes so after i said oh [ __ ] maybe i'm
making him too strong because he was
telling me where he was maybe i'm making
him too strong
a human died
well i mean at first
he gave me some i was like god damn
they're [ __ ] strong
but
he told me look you want to put a
grammar hash in each one so i was like
all right [ __ ] it too much did i start
putting your grandma started making them
too too much well he was telling me that
you know he actually sold him actually
didn't sound but he gave it to
one of his friends to his dad bro tell
them the circumstances of the dad well
that was you know of course the dad had
issues his dad was on his deathbed he
was in hospice yeah
okay he was in hospice different but
it's funnier to say it that way
i'm not lying yeah so you know yeah so
it was something like that so he
ended up taking a brawl and terrible
storytelling took him out bro
you're an awful storyteller state what
happened well i mean [ __ ] bro it was it
was it was pretty
it was pretty uh that's [ __ ] up
i'm not trying to say this because this
guy
starts saying all the whole details that
i don't want because then [ __ ] bro
whatever you'll be like whoa [ __ ]
pitching my boys dad and you know
[ __ ]
[ __ ] it's a story that's true that's
true and not just you guys know
obviously when the family goes what
happened like oh we got him
who knows what if they didn't even
[ __ ] tell anybody it's not like the
weed killed him you know he was gonna
die he just got to go to sleep in a deep
ass sleep if he ate the hash brown and
got i went to sleep and he just passed
away like how long after that night
yeah
but he finally got to go to sleep he was
super sick okay
he was about to die
yes he was he was on his deathbed would
he have died that night had he not that
probably probably maybe a few days after
a few couples but it's not even that his
body got so sedated he went like okay
buddy was so damn [ __ ] numb he just
his body was like oh [ __ ] thank god
we're not right i'm pretty sure that's
what happened yeah he just got so his
body went thank god i'm finally chilling
yeah what happened but they were they
were they were pretty strong i mean [ __ ]
i took one
let's see i took one right before i was
i was gonna baptize them
i was gonna baptize uh you know my god
my godson
and we had to go to these classes for
her church classes and all that i popped
that cookie bro
oh my god
[ __ ] i was just watching
somebody the father comes out and starts
talking bro and i'm right there [ __ ]
tripping balls bro like please just kill
the guy don't you dare [ __ ] pass
harder because you're in front of the
father bro you're [ __ ] up you know
and the father's talking i'm just like
[ __ ] i'm saying i'm like oh [ __ ] oh man
i'm gonna [ __ ] pass out right here
i'm a party
[ __ ] you know and i'm just like dunk
a baby in water bro i was [ __ ]
tripping
balls bro and they're like i was like
[ __ ] why did i take this [ __ ] i took it
all early thinking i'll be cool by this
time [ __ ] no like it hit me right when
we pulled up and i got off the car like
bam twilight's home welcome you know
what i mean i'm just like son of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was [ __ ] horrible
bad and that's when you go these [ __ ]
cookies
did you dunk the baby hold on did you
find it was the baby thing before or
after you gave them no this was the
classes that you had to go to no was it
before or after the dad died
oh no this was still i want to say
before yeah so you knew how [ __ ]
strong they were and you said yeah give
him this on his bed no no no bro we all
just said hey this will help you sleep
of course the guy willingly took him
goes yes please you don't need something
i mean somebody can't sleep when i guess
they're having pain and they can't sleep
yeah just give them that and you're
gonna knock them out but i mean i mean
[ __ ] if it's gonna take you out it's
gonna take you out bro because i mean
you're like already in your last days
yeah yeah for sure your body's just
waiting for you to rest like you go you
know what i mean so
he's just sitting there agonizing yeah
exactly he's right there fighting and
fighting and what that does to you it's
a date zebra where you [ __ ]
you know you [ __ ] your body just
rests and that's where you get to leave
you know
no i get it yeah and [ __ ] i [ __ ] get
it so you know that was about that was
part of that pills yeah these [ __ ]
cookies were [ __ ] strong so let's
just say this they they hit you good
oh yeah i literally stopped making them
he stopped making them at one grand i
stopped me i just made half grams of
hash you know i mean instead of putting
four grams
that's how i imagine it damn boy we
[ __ ] died yeah if we die hey we got
to start making them not as strong huh
yeah bro let's just go half
hey you got any more
and that's what happened hey you got any
more
and nothing ever stopped
because that sounds bomb yeah
yeah i've never i've never had an edible
hit me like that well yesterday i did
it happened to me yesterday
the hash brownies from john
is hash pop tarts
are the strongest edible i've ever had
if i have one more i'll give you it is
that what you had yesterday no no but i
had the 200 milligram the only 200
milligram hash pop tarts made of his
hash it's like a 8 2 000 milligrams
normal yeah oh the hash
oh [ __ ] god the hash
edibles
old school [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh the
cordova black bar yeah yeah thousand
milligrams we talked about that recently
on the show first
oh [ __ ]
yeah i wish i could find the stupid
qriket it's so loud
oh we're 2 12 in yeah not bad oh yeah
we're doing okay you're all right you're
not scared you haven't cried you haven't
texted me once and said i can't like sit
next to you
usually text him next to me like yo can
i sleep at the foot of your bed even
though he lives far
he always asks you that's crazy he
always says damn form out of high socks
do you have any high socks he always
asks me that too
imagine this guy at a high school
football game and competitive ass
[ __ ] imagine this high
[ __ ] slightly drunk in a
competitive high school football game
for his son yeah oh it's going to be bad
i want to go to your killing all those
games either with you
i'ma sit [ __ ] six i'm gonna sit
over
i don't want to be right next to you no
i don't drink it as games
but um
i don't want [ __ ] now when i show up
to these [ __ ] games some parents
recognize me like yeah they're all drunk
he's drunk
well you know i [ __ ] found a couple
of beers just to get into the game bro
you know my son's clean yeah you want a
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] slipping i gotta
start getting [ __ ]
he's eight though this fool's [ __ ]
17.
not eight-year-old cam yo his son
let's juke and [ __ ] out there
that's right bro we'll show you some
videos after this fool is juking
fools was it first and second touch
touchdowns
[Applause]
yesterday
he kind of pulled me aside at practice
he's like
can i call this one can i have dibs on
this kid when he's about 16.
he's like it's just so nice that i can
just give him the ball and i know we're
just going to score each time i give him
and let the other kids touch the ball
like for the rest of the game yeah bro
he got eight touchdowns his first game
and they pulled him oh they're like yo
we got to sit down and let everybody
else play you gotta hurt that's right so
did i when i played soccer they made me
sit down
you'll get it later you'll understand
why later but yo these [ __ ] kids [ __ ]
and they're not gonna be able to play
that much and don't worry you're gonna
score six touchdowns tomorrow
all right i'm gonna do pull-ups while
i'm waiting that's his kid bro
for sure [ __ ] yeah it's awesome yeah it
is bro i mean [ __ ] having your kids
[ __ ] plays oh yeah
first thing he did after his facetime
thomas tell him about his stats and chat
yep he facetimed me he's like so you
know i only got two touchdowns today i
go bro but i watched them both and they
were both in the same two same two
drives like how many runs did you get
they only gave me the balls twice but so
you scored two times on two touches
this falls faster now you're just juking
kids it's not fun it's not fair you can
see even from the back angle
that he already dusted the kid the
[ __ ] kids of safety yeah and he
already you can see him he's like oh
he's gone
[ __ ] kid watching he's about 16 where
we watch this game right now eight oh
[ __ ] yeah it's good bro he's dusting
kids and juking them and works out i
know i've never gotten more reactions
from a story on instagram
people like damn that kid
he just he juked the kid into a baseball
slide
this fool is is dope
um believe it or not
volleyball
all high school volleyball team emoji
played four years
well no he played volleyball and he
would always put the glass on the back
of his head when he'd serve
and then you go serve a sack
am i right
you never played men's volleyball no i
could have swore you played men's
volleyball and you guys only high five
with your chest bumps
and your big naked woman tattoo would
stick to that kid
he has the same tattoos as danny trejo
all down his whole body it's crazy and
danny trejo has an og-76 tattoo which is
crazy too
oh you saw him at a beach and he was a
kid and goes yo that's my name now
that's not his real name he got it from
danny trejo's tattoo on his ribs right
that's him
about fast [ __ ] [ __ ] mexican
bluff of [ __ ]
hey how'd you like that
how'd you like that it's pretty good i
have another question i'm eating more
edibles
i have a question
uh can you tell us a story
story about
the time you saw hello people running on
your block covered in blood in the 80s
oh [ __ ] from the restaurant
can you talk about that since you're not
affiliated with this [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the 80s but say like you say
tell it good
tell us why well i have a story behind
it i'm not going to say 100 percent i'm
pretty sure yeah someone who's approved
it i heard someone tell me a story but
yeah
there was a wedding [ __ ]
at a hall right down the street from
where i live
let's tell the story after you've done
crunching chips
[ __ ] i guess
i believe it was uh
80s right yeah one of the ex-boyfriends
went back
and [ __ ] shot up the whole place bro
you're such a bad storyteller
they were having a [ __ ] wedding
reception right next to his house at a
hall somebody came through and shot up
the entire [ __ ] wedding party like
bro sick yeah
apparently apparently i've never been on
live television before
oh yeah
well anyways there was a [ __ ] there
was a wedding and this guy
shot up almost everybody with a gun an
automatic gun there are a lot of people
there was [ __ ] um literally people
literally parked on my block that went
to people [ __ ] running with
literally [ __ ] shot bleeding
[ __ ] next [ __ ] everybody going
back to the car literally shot everybody
parked on this block because there was
no parking there was a [ __ ] there was
people like literally [ __ ] just like
running down the street bro yelling and
screaming hysterically [ __ ] one guy
carrying him [ __ ] two people carrying
him to a car throwing in the back car
you know about to see the car taking up
all crazy
and i was like i want to say i was about
[ __ ]
[ __ ] i was like about
seven or six years old bro you know and
[ __ ]
i just tripped out like god damn bro
like what's happening and i'm listening
to you know my brother my friends are
like oh [ __ ] they just [ __ ] they just
shot up everybody right here at the
wedding
and [ __ ] uh yeah really [ __ ]
this guy was [ __ ] crazy looking at
everybody how he killed the he killed
the
groom and brian you know what i mean
i'm [ __ ] some crazy [ __ ]
and uh not so long ago maybe not maybe a
while back like maybe about 10 years ago
we went to uh one of my boys [ __ ] got
married in there
we went in there bro and [ __ ] bro you
can just feel the [ __ ] like there's
like some kind of vibe in there bro
[ __ ] horrible it's tough to come back
from that feels hot in there it feels
kind of like it was just something
trippy like [ __ ] this you know what i
mean
and i just i'll just remember what
happened there when i was a kid and i
was like damn this [ __ ] was crazy
[ __ ] pretty crazy [ __ ] bro seeing
people [ __ ]
literally [ __ ]
thinking they're done
i'm [ __ ] seven six years old so i'm
just like [ __ ] yo [ __ ]
sorry follow another question
why didn't i think about this
you grew up in l.a
you were in the gangbanger dumb [ __ ]
when you were a young kid you guys were
selling drugs did you guys know of rick
ross
um
what a question not here from you you
were around you didn't know about rick
ross because it was over there and you
guys are mexicans and they're black
people
so you didn't know about how much money
they were getting
we have our own but crack leaked into
east l.a oh for sure but we already
probably had our own um you're already
making it over there everything yeah
we're cooking it coming bringing our
remate yeah i'll show you guys oh yeah
if it was all still
yeah
so you guys never heard about this fool
making a billion dollars on the other
side of town i don't know that's crazy
maybe because because you guys were
mexican it was just a difference
especially back then it was
a race thing completely yeah no and then
you're saying it's just the whole not
allowed to really do that
you know there ain't no black people in
east telly you know i mean so it's like
it wasn't none of that was really talked
about you know because you know we were
i get it so you know it's just a
question thinking like yo you guys in
the same town the same time doing the
same [ __ ] dude i mean don't get me wrong
i'm pretty sure you know [ __ ] i mean
it's like with like nwa and like music
for sure you'll hear it
like we knew what that was you know but
not really it's just it's different
apart it's like it's too far you know i
mean it's like that [ __ ] with south
central compton you know we're over here
in east valley it's like we have a home
like yeah it's like queens and brooklyn
bronx and all that stuff
for everybody out there the reason we
got rick ross on the up on the channel
on the podcast because of this guy he
knows rick ross now yeah that's just one
do you know or hear about that
[ __ ] yeah bro actually i read
his book bro and [ __ ] bro
i was like i was amazing
[ __ ] [ __ ] smart [ __ ] man you
know i mean [ __ ] he literally [ __ ]
smart guy he did it bro he [ __ ] yeah
you know he masterminded [ __ ] bro have
that many employees is crazy [ __ ] you
can't even manage three dudes you give
qps to like a little [ __ ] thousand
fifteen hundred [ __ ] selling
bags
yeah and then back then we didn't have
social media yeah it was easier like
everything's easier back you know 90s we
didn't have social media and all that
[ __ ] you know we did have internet [ __ ]
bro it's like oh our cousin got the
internet because yeah you know she could
afford to go to her house and be right
there whatever we could find and [ __ ]
you know but
you know even that you know it wasn't as
popular as now of course now it's like
[ __ ] but back then i'm pretty sure we
would have heard of homeboy you know i
mean
it's a trip though man amazing yeah for
sure
i just had to ask that question like oh
yeah that would have been a trip i don't
know that was making that much i mean
i'm pretty sure he had something to do
with it even though no matter oh of
course of course yeah it's a crack in
l.a oh first of all for sure always you
know there's a chain
it goes down so how does that work does
like
since it's their neighborhood you guys
don't even involve like anybody from
that would never even go over there huh
no no no like section we have no
business state yeah we have no business
on it you mean basically if you're out
there and you're looking for trolling
[ __ ] you're literally probably asking
for it then yeah i mean you have no
business out there what are you doing
out there you know what i mean like like
a fool
you know it's the same thing you know
they have no business over here the same
[ __ ] you know
you know back and forth
and not saying like fool we're going to
get food at this mom at spa that's
different yeah oh yeah i'm not saying
like why are you standing on a
blockchain so cracked too you can get
shot yeah well now it's different now
you could do that like no no yeah i've
always wanted to eat over there and i do
that you know i mean i don't that
doesn't you know that's it's different
but back then in the 90s it wasn't
hell no it was still you got gotta watch
out you get run up on this [ __ ] you know
what i mean yeah no joke see mercedes 20
years back in 2010
when i was about when i was just getting
out of high school like 2007-8
there was a big uh black mexican war
going on oh yeah they were shooting the
[ __ ] out of each other bro and we're 20
years back you guys you're in the 90s
we're doing 2010. telling you merced is
20 years late all the gang [ __ ] it's
still a little bit ignorant over there
i'm not saying mercedes i'm saying some
[ __ ] that live there like bro
why are you still hitting up fools that
aren't affiliated you could see it on
their [ __ ] faces they're not well
because basically now you know you got a
lot of foods that don't even look like a
gang member
but as soon as they respond and go no
man i'm just you know getting food they
look it doesn't schedule now you know
you don't look for like the gang member
type two now you get to listen yeah but
that means you're hitting that
boy with this with this beard and all
that that's what you look for now oh
yeah yeah i get that lined up kids yeah
you know i mean that's what you look for
now the gucci belt you know yeah
weighing all that [ __ ] all that fancy
[ __ ] bro those are the ones you look out
for now i get it i understand you know
they're not really you know anything
with a slight tattoo right here and a
gucci belt like
a little cross
yeah
they got they're all lined up with the
haircut everything so
sometimes you know they do this a lot
yeah they're going to scam you
any guy that touches his hands like this
a lot like he's a scammer i [ __ ] just
trust me
please
just scam your ass and some guys right
now watching this going oh [ __ ]
i was about to scam this kid right here
we're watching it together oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay now somebody's thought that's our
homie
[ __ ] he did just play me for ten sec i'm
telling you you're gonna watch out for
the hand rubbers
those [ __ ] are doing this to
stall so they can think about how to get
you
i'm telling you
yeah mercedes back it's late yeah yeah
for sure yeah that's what i heard it's a
little backed up on
yeah i mean [ __ ]
now with the internet bro they should be
caught up already
i don't know i'm just speaking on the
last time i've experienced things and
maybe it's changed i mean it's been five
years i haven't lived there so five
years oh [ __ ] yeah bro maybe it's
changed yeah because i go back there
there's nobody outside
not even on 12th street when i go back
to look at my old my grandma's i always
go back to just take a lap around
my grandma's neighborhood
i mean
there's nobody outside there's nobody
outside which is crazy that's a good
thing man yeah no it's a good thing i'm
looking at like nobody's sitting outside
staring at people like nothing's going
on
i think the fools now that you have to
worry about like in the valley or the 35
year old dudes they got nothing to
[ __ ]
are the old school school fools are the
ones that are like whoa
come on man i'm [ __ ] i'm on grub hub
delivering food [ __ ] this is a
work shirt like i don't know like that's
the kind of [ __ ] i think like damn those
fools are ignorant
yeah i'm not saying all of them are i'm
saying you guys all know somebody that's
like dude you're still on that [ __ ] how
old are you
we all know that guys before we just
said you love it yeah that's your thing
people you know
one of my cousins rest in peace and he
was [ __ ] that much he was like 57 bro
and he was still [ __ ] on it bro he
was even giving [ __ ] what
yeah he even had his he tattooed his
eyebrows and he put game over
and he would tell us oh yeah you know
what when i die you're gonna you're
gonna see that in this man
sure enough
how do you pass away he passed away you
know
i believe yeah you got shot he passed
away at 57. yeah for sure you feel a 57
year old man you're an [ __ ] i'm
telling you
it was like he was he shot an elderly
man i thought he was still like 21 years
old he's a senior citizen you know what
i mean yeah but you shot a senior
citizen man [ __ ] yo
you know you got some old small [ __ ]
out there still so damn
over on his face yes he was all tattered
and he had game over it's your cousin
you never told me about your cousin we
literally said we're like [ __ ] it was
right you just said it's the last thing
you're gonna say like maybe because it's
on your eyebrows and not your eyes
of course you're gonna see it it feels
crazy yeah when you close because it's
crazy oh on his eyelids his eyelids oh
they said
yeah no on his eyes such a sick tattoo i
thought you said his eyebrows
of course of course you're gonna have
your eyes closed so it's a game over on
his eyes awesome that's like a villain
yeah that's some pre like i always said
yo if the world ever like does a quick
flash freeze over you're all about to
freeze to death or some crazy [ __ ] i'm
gonna pose hella sick yeah so when they
[ __ ] find us uh million years from
now like yo
new civilization look at look at this
[ __ ] posing like squatting down
all the time
i'm like yo and then they're gonna put
me on the money i know so for some
people it's life bro if that's all they
live for you know okay back to the game
making sure yeah i know some people you
know i mean they love it so much that
[ __ ]
until the wheels fall off yeah i get it
i understand
some people just like that and that's
cool if that's how you're gonna live but
just you know yeah beat up your own
people that are gonna gain me that's not
sure that's all i ask i never said you
can stop or have to stop just saying
just don't you know hit up
jeebus
homie jebus does not look like a gay man
you gotta hit jesus up at the bar don't
do that
it's not right
well jesus is liking dumb then james was
just going to the bathroom
we're in a michael jordan shirt no i'm
just saying you know what i mean because
there's some monkeys that just [ __ ] i
know i thought you know i mean i've been
to some spots with god damn bro i've
been treated like
really poor i'm not like i'm not even
being an aggressive one and [ __ ]
this guy's coming at me pretty crazy you
know what i mean a little no g went
straight who the [ __ ] side you want he
forgot that he asked him what team you
like you forgot about the whole thing
huh no i think it also my birthday we
went to [ __ ] uh what was it the
what was this [ __ ] club called it was
the branding iron movie [ __ ] studio
54. one other one
chick-fil-a know what those [ __ ]
night at the roxbury bro yes so there's
a nightclub called roxbury we went bro
i'd go there we thought it was going to
be like some [ __ ] you know cool it's
chris katan
yeah it was something else bro but we
still had our table will ferrell
stranger than fiction not funny
yeah it was pretty local for something
yeah we're not not at the rocks
but i mean [ __ ] it the farm will just
have fun but that bro there were some
people in there that literally got chest
bumped you literally told me like what
the [ __ ] are you doing in here no [ __ ]
right up yo you ready wanna see how did
you get pissed
hey did anybody recently not let you in
a restaurant because the way you looked
that train is bringing a bunch of hate
right now yeah hey anybody recently at a
restaurant um
say the whole story you're a terrible
story
i mean okay so [ __ ] i was getting
some food from my boss
and [ __ ] your boss is a white dude
and he always goes to super fancy
restaurant senzog's asked to get it this
time
continue hold on you're bad at this they
called before to ask if takeout was
still working they said yes we do take
out yeah yeah
you know say that you know so i'm like
all right so i'm driving around i can't
find it and i call the restaurant i'm
like hey i can't find you guys what are
you doing oh we're right here they're
all cool still
all right cool okay [ __ ] i'm going to
get out of the store
i start walking into the restaurant
i mean into the little [ __ ] center
and then i see it like oh [ __ ] that's it
i get there
right when the guy looked at me like he
went like what the [ __ ] like and he
looked at me up and i was like
how can i help you and i was just like
oh i'm trying to
get take out he's like oh
[Music]
isn't that what you guys could do is i
could order takeout because it's colby
you thought nope sorry not right here no
i go you know what i go we just call
right now and you know he goes no no we
don't do take out i'm sorry you know if
you it's only dine like oh so maybe i'll
dine in and take my food i was already
starting to talk [ __ ] and then i cut
myself i checked myself i go you know
what that's fine you know i'm out of
here i walked out of there and i was
just like
you know what you should have [ __ ]
done
you know what you should have done which
i don't know why you didn't you should
have called me to pull some ferris
bueller [ __ ] i've been hey the guy that
sells the most beef in california the
big the guys in there and you know what
is he wearing he's wearing probably a
raiders hat some big pants and jays
yeah he kind of talks like this man and
you know if you don't i'm waiting on a
meeting to give him a million dollar
check
we should have pulled some ferris
dealership why did you do that
you should i would have called the
restaurant dude you know what it was i
couldn't even find this restaurant it
was bro and i was [ __ ] already
driving around like literally for like
almost no that's not what it was what it
was they judged the [ __ ] out of you
unless you ordered yeah and then i got
judged for literally driving
only pause is what he pulled on you from
life
that's what he did to you what's the
restaurant called so we can all say hey
man i love that restaurant uh was it uh
it's in culver city paris time or
something paris rosie google it so we
can talk [ __ ]
what's the place in culver city it's a
restaurant something paris
paris the word is paris it's in a
restaurant look up restaurant in culver
city in paris that's all
night oh yeah i don't know if it's not
all night we're gonna put him on blast
these ferris bueller [ __ ] was
he french like in ferris bueller
did he have an accident
you know what maybe he reminded me of
that [ __ ] ticket oh man that would
make that action
[ __ ] you know just instead of us
doing cool ferris dealership we'll just
tell everybody what the name is so they
cannot eat there because they [ __ ]
discriminate against gangbangers
you look like a game hanger for sure i
didn't have the [ __ ] master they were
like no no he doesn't have a mask he
wears a [ __ ] bandana around his face
[ __ ]
what do you mean
stop
you can't wear only white dudes with
[ __ ] boots
i mean if you got yelp from one minute
they tell me on the phone yeah you can
go ahead and when you walk in and i go
no we don't do take out because of covet
which makes no sense
and then he went oh yeah sorry so we
just don't do it
that's some [ __ ] and rosie looked
and there's about three other reviews on
their yelp for them doing the same [ __ ]
to people and they're like i just walked
out
there's multiple people said the same
[ __ ] oh hell yeah and they're [ __ ]
jerks from the [ __ ] gate then yep
yeah [ __ ] idiots yeah so anyway that
was [ __ ] awesome like i love it marty
don't you love it
already got pulled over one time because
he was white
no for real because he was in the drug
neighborhood and they're like yo this
white kid's getting drugs how funny is
that though is i love breaking it up
it's funny it's the only time you get
discriminated against for being white is
[ __ ] hilarious yeah if you're an
easterly and you you know
you're driving like a little like a
little bucket car oh
that's him yeah for sure what are you
doing you know speaking of [ __ ]
um how was the crack era in east l.a in
the 90s because we know what it was like
in talking to rick ross bro [ __ ] it was
funny what do you mean it was good you
should smoke crack bro don't be saying
it was good it was good i mean [ __ ]
because
i mean [ __ ] i mean
[ __ ] actually i had a friend that was
actually you know they were making it
so this guy it started off with hey
you want to put this you put this in
your weed and it's going to be good and
you know rest in peace my boy you know
that was the cricket sneezing guys by
the way
like a little peace small cookie
and god damn bro we're like all right
back then like i said we used to roll up
primes you know primos pita i can see
dogs you know if i can put it with the
weed and
and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] we got you know we were selling it
and smoking people you guys should have
called him pee wee herman's yeah
that would have been [ __ ] funny you
might make more people want to smoke it
he was popular than 90s he's still tight
i would have called it pw
oh if i ever start smoking crack i'm
going to call myself pw herman and
smoking it no
you know i'm gonna smoke crack just to
make that baller ass name it was all
about
mister partying and then [ __ ] smoking
some crack at the end of the night so
disgusting bro end it off with some
crack
ended off with some crack
that was [ __ ] what a piece of [ __ ]
you know back then you just partying
[ __ ] that was called partying bro that's
called the end of your life
yeah i mean it was something that we
would just do during the weekends friday
saturday and then you know sunday
through
friday we just back on the ball hustling
selling again we're not making our money
and yeah when it came to the weekend
that's what we would you were those
dudes that you didn't want yeah
literally we already had a big old piece
we had a stack of paper and it was like
[ __ ] this is really let's smoke it
just smoke it off [ __ ] it damn i would
have not been friends with you guys real
quick oh yeah bro it was pretty local
you know but i took my lighter i caught
it for i cut it quick you know
at the same time i wasn't that dumb i
still had my car i was still i still had
my car
yo marty you know if you're smoking
crack you still got your car you got
your [ __ ] together
i was i
think or 12th grade i mean [ __ ] are you
serious that's the guy's [ __ ]
cadillac
oh yeah i know that
i smoked crack for the first time i was
in 11th grade
yeah i mean
but i stopped that immediately it was
just more like
i did it but i seen what i was
attracting like i said i was attracting
my own people yeah and that's what i
didn't want so that's why i [ __ ]
[ __ ] you they said i saw wheat yeah
yeah i think we talked about this last
time right for sure
yeah
but so the crack era back then what was
it like do you see because it's more
meth over there
it's not really cracked like it was it
was at least it wasn't as bad as metal
right now these people are methods
it's it's even like not even biker math
not even the bathtub oh yeah it's even
worse no no it's not that crazy biker
method's crank yeah it's that's my dad
you know what yeah
crank
now that's [ __ ] [ __ ] crystal
crystal meth and [ __ ] that shit's
[ __ ] smells like zombies you guys
[ __ ] tripping
acting like something else you know what
i mean that's that's the worst thing you
can do right now man if you [ __ ] with
that man bro you're just
setting yourself up bro
you're gone for a [ __ ]
early [ __ ] just
nothing bro you're just [ __ ] it's not
gonna end well i mean yeah shit's
[ __ ] ain't no joke bro
that's just
something else
hey
leading to your [ __ ] microphone
i can't hear you
you know what when i did the [ __ ]
testing
it was sounded just good
i know but you can't hear what i'm
hearing i hear this
and then i was like smoking crack and
then uh
i just hear like every other word oh
really yeah something a car pass oh [ __ ]
stupid that's what it sounds like
and your mic keeps moving too bro you
know what sucks all of a sudden it moves
by itself you moved it i didn't i
promise
uh i was supposed to get my car tonight
yeah what happened to chin up getting it
nope
they didn't even take me back
oh hey dude yeah stupid oh yeah
what what's my phone how is this my
phone yeah because you were saying
they're going to call me back today it's
going to be ready no you didn't do you
know what they text me
it takes me at 6 and said hey don't come
in at 6.
thanks for the heads up ready
this is not studio motors by the way for
everyone out there knowing i [ __ ] with
studio motors is not studio mode damn
marty with a re-up thank you
um
the people that are wrapping my car told
me coming at six and they said i said
is it done they go don't come in at six
like okay
i said what time's gonna be done they go
we'll hit you up a little bit and then i
hit him up at 7 30 and go hey what
time's the car going to be done they go
hey the emblems aren't back on but you
can come pick it up and i went
well
but the emblems aren't on
to
and i call and go so yo
should i pick it up because yeah but the
emblems aren't done yet
and i go so
should i just it's not it's not done no
it's not done but you can pick up the
car
i went bro i'm just gonna wait till
you're [ __ ] done what are you talking
about
and that's how this night ended oh [ __ ]
was he mad no i don't [ __ ] know her
care i just know like yo you told me
tuesday i dropped it off friday
tomorrow's thursday
yeah i had my car from run just to
change my chrome it's cause you know
these guys get so much [ __ ] work bro
they get so trust to change my chrome
it's because i'm telling you bro i'm
telling you that you and there's like
[ __ ] 15 other people
behind you don't take my job not that
tell me it's thursday don't tell me it's
tuesday and then monday it's not that's
all no just be truthful but yo i'm so
backed up i'm gonna need two extra days
like bro fine that's totally cool cause
i'm not gonna be sitting here every
morning going oh [ __ ] yeah my car
supposed to be here today
yeah no you gotta always expect that bro
i i didn't know that you know i i look
at put to say i just did my breaks
they're supposed to do my breaks yeah
that's this week that's [ __ ] and the
same thing you know what i mean i mean
i mean but i knew it already i know
there's no way it's gonna happen yeah
you know and you dude was busy and i
knew no but i knew there was a chance of
it and i took that chance but listen to
what i'm saying at the end of the day
come pick your car up but it's not done
that we the stuff you want it's not done
but then i'll just wait yeah no it
wasn't there but no i couldn't even yeah
do you understand what i'm trying to be
somewhere in the next one
i'm saying me oh no you yeah that's a
dumb thing to tell but hey come in it's
not done what the [ __ ] yeah what the
[ __ ] hey your food was almost done here
hey
i'll give it give us over what they were
supposed to do is what they didn't
but i just thought it was weird like yo
are you high [ __ ] were you calling them
maybe too many times and they're like i
just text them
sunday and then today oh [ __ ] no
yeah but you know sometimes you see they
got a lot of work and then no i know but
they get they get frustrated bro just by
even texting them once like this yo
should i trim these they're not done yet
should i chop this plant down it's not
done
it's like hey i'll just wait
tell me when it's done that's all i just
thought it was funny i'm just talking
[ __ ]
hey man i thought it was funny
i don't know for me it's hilarious
people say stupid things to me yeah no
for sure i mean [ __ ] maybe just
the guys are cool they're super nice
dudes
that was a funny thing to say they're
backed up and they're just trying to
[ __ ] if i tell you i'll be there at
six i'll be there at six
yeah but now you should be twelve and be
like
close to six you gotta annoy it don't
work like that bro i don't know but just
be truthful
anyway onto something else taking the
shot ready
the reason i brought up the car because
i thought of the shot went oh i got to
drive still and i went way on the car
that's what brought it up sorry i got
all off topic that's why i brought that
up right now
all right look at cheers there we go
what are you drinking again oh same [ __ ]
tequila
that was the roughest one
all right so back to your old episode
the one you came on
how did you like it man yeah
did you like it
you didn't [ __ ] cut out my
cut out some spots all day address it
address it tell marty's changing the
camera right now
what happened marty you're supposed to
uh
edit it oh don't worry yeah we're
editing all this yeah don't worry about
it
but so i'm watching the show turn around
[ __ ] literally once i seen that i
literally turned the [ __ ] i turned it
off like what the best
[Music]
no because i even call him dude you left
and he goes
sometimes i i skim through block by
block i was like what yeah i was like
all right if not you're listening to the
edit three times the whole footage too
i'm eating three of these gummies right
now
oh bomb there
no i still got some right i'm not trying
you're taking bites
but also that [ __ ] didn't even strike me
is that big of a mistake i might have
even left it in if i meant it to leave
it in because yeah it was fun it was
good i've never actually really taken
anything out where it wasn't like
somebody had to go to the bathroom or
something we've never like really edited
it out
my good
it's our weekend gummy so we're all rude
eating gummies on the microphone my bad
guys i watched it after you know i just
you know your angle is terrible it's
just me i don't [ __ ] i'm not into
it's like half on the machine sorry
we're technically it's the last episode
of the season guys all right usually i
would never say this [ __ ] on camera i
would let it go my a your camera fell
halfway through the [ __ ] video
it's the last season it's the last
episode okay
yeah it did
all right
so you like your episode huh did you
like it pretty cool i guess it's funny
watching this guy get embarrassed that's
all right i think it's [ __ ] great
bother me i mean it took me a minute so
it really it took you six months
was it that's how long it been bro i
don't know how long it's been but it
took a long time you watched it today
i finished watching it that's what i
just said watching you know i get that
but you didn't finish it till today
yeah i did i kind of reviewed it today i
reviewed it today i liked you guys's
work
i approved thomas
you're a jerk they played at the [ __ ]
shop and he'll change it
shout out to dgbg for always playing our
[ __ ] seriously but
i think it's funny with this fool's
embarrassed about being on camera that
he agreed to sure i'll make him turn it
off
that's the best part
mindy
why is this [ __ ] so embarrassed
so embarrassed about nothing you should
have seen it when he uh
i'm just gonna put you on blast and
everything he peed his pants one time
with me
we were at the mexican tacoma shop and
he was just like i don't know what to
order or what to order i can't make it
he's pissed
he was so tight remember remember i held
your hand yeah
and when they mopped it up
yeah the cool kids pee their pants only
cool kids pee their pants and then pee
in your pants is cool considering me
miles davis
okay
that's from blood and blood out
really yep damn bro that's from blood
and blood out
bolivia you [ __ ] it's billy
madison
oh okay okay you got me because they
[ __ ] up you played that good really
[ __ ] love blood and blood oh i can
recite all blood and blood out i know
the whole [ __ ] movie it's one of the
only tapes my dad had
blood and blood out very bad oh no not
very bad thing blood and blood out your
uncle's coming
once in a while the movie never no all
my hopes have good jobs
have good ass jobs don't come around
because they're busy
they all do stuff like because my
grandmother grabbed me back in the night
bro vhs
[ __ ] oh got passed around everywhere
everybody's thinking we're landing in
this [ __ ] no i was at my grandma's house
blood and blood out double impact those
are the four i can remember off the top
of my head
chocolate that damn double impact where
he plays his own brother
that's a good one
blood sport we too yeah blood sport we
had two
buzzwords cool you got kind of domino i
remember someone but john clavin dam is
one of the one of the guys you don't
like when you think of action stars you
never go john coffin no one ever says
that sure because arnold schwarzenegger
and semester stallone dominated so hard
he's scotty pippen
of action movies who's one of the best
basketball players ever you never say
scotty pippin even though he's one of
the best basketball players ever
and so jean-claude van damme can
actually beat the [ __ ] out of arnold
and
sebastian stallone in real life
he's the one that's really doing all
that [ __ ]
yet you never say he's the action star
yeah they kind of took over they took
over too hard just like michael jordan
and kobe but you never say scotty pippen
was amazing even though he is
that's [ __ ] up
i don't like your little input i like
your little input on this
[Laughter]
you could just say thomas you said
everything needs to be said i don't have
to have any input on this because you
said it
i'm like you're right
i'm like you're right you're right as he
[ __ ] plots on me what the [ __ ] you
doing over here it scared me
yeah how long we've been here 247 ah we
can start winding down you've been here
long enough that's [ __ ] good you've
been here for a while yeah you had a
[ __ ] interview
you got me right here in the interview
that i agreed to and left work early and
came over here you act like i'm forcing
you with the gun that's this is a fake
arm by the way i have a gun underneath
the table
this has been a fake arm the whole time
making sure he stays once upon a time in
mexico this is it right here yeah i have
a gun underneath the table
so man
how you doing
yeah lost that joint how you doing how
you feeling pretty good man
i gave you a whole lighter
you did yeah oh [ __ ] right look it's
underneath your foot that means you've
dropped it
i've had the lighter the whole time i
mean i do have three four angles of it
you're lucky i'm saying otherwise they
would be in my pocket right now you luck
you got a little [ __ ] feet must be
stomping around on those [ __ ]
that's one of my favorite lines of any
movie ever
that's from harsh times
you look at your little [ __ ] feet
hey
john claude van damme double impact
that's where we're at talking about
nothing
all right real quick last question was
the first time you ever did hard drugs
first time i ever did hardcore coke meth
pcp crank crack doesn't matter
first time what can you remember
13 13 sam
they started off with crack
[Music]
yeah before i sold it
damn son where'd you smoke this
where'd you smoke it at well i'm telling
you that's a real question i have a
girlfriend back then and that's what we
used to when you got
mutually let go from your home you
smoked crack oh yeah you thought that
was the best decision to smoke crack
cools you mean dip pcp cigarettes huh
pcp cigarette dips
uh yeah
actually no they were with weed
wheat on the pcb
a lovely
uh uh uh i think it was it was lovely
it's a lovely i remember my mom saying
lovely yeah pcp dipped wheat
i don't know mom put in the chat mama
you know she's in the chat mom what's
the pcp tips
that's what philippe said i remember he
said lovely yeah okay yeah
pcp is very explosive
that's blood and blood out
it was pretty i think i was wet like i
think i was just at 13 14
no 13 crack and then 14 pcp i like pcp
it makes it when it fools and their
heads are all big what movie is that
from
is that pl uh uh chichen chang
oh yeah i don't walk
yeah that's how i felt when i smoked pcc
i felt like like i explained it i felt
like my head was drifting away and i was
floating away
i felt like i was doing this
i couldn't control my body and it felt
like i was going in and out of my body
like i couldn't control it you know
those mexican toys that they're a statue
but you press the button on the bottom
they go
and then you let go of it and they stand
back up yeah yeah that's how i fell on
pcp [ __ ] i felt like i was on a jumper
you know yeah bouncing back if you're
running like we literally i still
remember you know me and my me and my
grandfather we thought we were [ __ ]
running and we're doing this and we're
we're doing this and they're literally
walking doing this
big pants and cortez's
the kids in the 90s speedwalking other
people looking at us saying dude what's
wrong with this guy he's walking they're
on pcp
yeah we're [ __ ] on pcp pcp sucks
i don't like that drug pretty local you
know i mean you know what i really want
to do in a really really i smoked it you
know what and i continue
one time in uh in the cemetery
that was the first time we did it too
you know and it's a halloween episode
yeah we had [ __ ] you know one of my
brother's friend with this and
he started just doing some crazy shea
bro
and started taking decorations from
harry potter all the other people
yeah
maybe this is where you got [ __ ]
haunted yeah maybe this is where you go
no this was no
hey man don't do that we're like [ __ ]
you know what maybe that's why they
fools that like me i would always say
some [ __ ] and
i guess maybe is whoever you know he
knew that the cemetery so he would
collect all that [ __ ] and bam make his
all nice and we're like [ __ ] he just
collected that from everywhere here yeah
but you're like all right i remember we
spoke some pcp there the guy that you
went with is he dead now
uh no i believe that oh okay because
that sounds like some [ __ ] you died for
in the haunting yeah no it was it wasn't
really that bad you know [ __ ] was really
that bad you [ __ ] just suspecting
people's graves in the cemetery on drugs
we did [ __ ] we did get pcp'd out that
day right at the cemetery
[ __ ] man i just remember like
everything just felt like [ __ ] it was
like like one big giant
[ __ ] balloon [ __ ] like you're just
bouncing
right in a big jumper
yeah in a good way or us
even just a cemetery i didn't like it
you know i mean like i mean you get
different different effects and
different stuff but that's the way i
felt i felt it like everything just went
on slow motion
like everything and you think you're
doing things a lot faster than you're
not you're [ __ ]
for other you know you in your own brain
you think you're doing this and i got
some weak aspects because that sounds
tight but i had sound like straight
anxiety panic attacks you know this [ __ ]
was cool i mean i'll tell you this one
time what happened look it i'll tell you
so
my cousin was let me tell you this more
[ __ ] this is this is your joey
diaz let me tell you let me tell you let
me tell you this was actually when i i
want to say i still was maybe about 13
years old so my cousin's smoking uh a
frio you know
a what
a freak [ __ ] a pcp you know [ __ ] a
coup
oh cool
don't be saying that in spanish all
right
you know what i mean so you know [ __ ]
they would dip the cool boom smoking it
so they're right there talking about
what they're gonna do and i'm right
there just [ __ ] literally the [ __ ]
little dumb [ __ ] kid just trying to be
nosy and trying to listen to what
they're saying is the first time first
time you ever smoked it this one yes
and i remember this who got it and he
threw it on the ground you know like it
and they all took off let's go so there
was like about i want to say about uh
maybe a little bit less than a quarter
of it
so what did i do i went i got it
and i smoked it stole my
so my aunt and my my mom were already
tripping out because saying hey these
guys you know my cousins they all took
off and they were high on drugs
and there i go
i'm [ __ ] smoking there i go yeah i'm
high on drugs too and i remember i
looked at me like
oh yeah sure you are
get the [ __ ] out here you know i mean
they didn't even believe that i was i
dude i was [ __ ] pcp the [ __ ] out too
bro
and they literally thought that i was
that i was pretending to be on it they
thought i was just [ __ ] acting it out
bro i was on pcp bro i was [ __ ] that
was the first time i [ __ ] ever really
really smoked it yeah you guys start
putting your butts out everybody it's
the first time i smoke a cigarette my
mom flicked a cigarette now go i'll be
right back the [ __ ] street
at the park and she drove to the store
and i picked it up i mean this why do
all the adults do this
and i almost threw the [ __ ] up
and screamed in the street like platoon
it hurt
so that's how you smoke pcp huh that was
the first time i smoked a piece of
people and i was [ __ ] that was i
remember [ __ ] i was [ __ ] on another
level what were you seeing like what was
going on i just felt like no it's like
it's not just my whole talking was just
slurring and everything and
have you ever been so [ __ ] up that
when you're talking something else to
get
yeah after that feeling goes away then
you feel like then you start feeling
like oh [ __ ] all right you know you can
do things there's no but at first you're
like frozen bro you're moving at normal
speed in your head yeah at first you're
you're [ __ ] but that's what you're
doing yeah oh that feeling's weird it's
like this
like you're not walking straight like
someone's pulling you back
seen fools [ __ ] like spiders on
the floor
they're like
[ __ ] you know like spiders oh yeah
[ __ ]
i see [ __ ] i've heard about you
know oh people i know that literally ran
down the street naked on pc people
smoking
absolutely [ __ ] yeah you know it just
smoked everybody has their [ __ ] you
know different
different effects
i don't tie the shoe right now in my
shoe actually underneath that
i just tied your [ __ ] laces together
look at my feet yeah with my foot
it was sick crazy
so that was your pcp time mine was not
fun i didn't know it was laced until i
was smoked in in oregon
when i got kicked out and smoked it up
there
and then trying to make it onto the
steps was weird and i thought i was just
you know
wow this weed's good and then when i got
close to the bathroom it was when i
realized
oh what i didn't smoke was not just weed
and i couldn't like touch what i touched
in the walls was like
michael jordan and a space jam when he's
like dunking that ball to win that's how
i felt like
like it was hard to
get to stuff like when people are
getting blown away by wind and movies
that's how i feel when i'm [ __ ] up on
the pcb
twice what's happening
for sure not f oh no once it was cracked
the other one i don't like crack crack
is nasty it smells like color crayons
melting
[ __ ]
[Music]
you know what made me laugh the guy the
artist was spray painting our set
justin
the artist was spray painting our set
does 94
paint smell just like coke
okay
because i asked tyler and i went
yo
because tyler's a grappler like he does
that [ __ ] i'm like yo does 94 because he
was using 94 i go
i just walked in i came back from the
store and i went is this full doing
rails in here
that's what i thought like yo is this
full chopping one up when i was gone
that's what i thought cause it stunk
like bricks
and then i asked tyler like yo does this
spray paint he says is it 94
and i go yeah it's 94 and he goes yeah
it smells a little bit like coke so
you're saying it's the ether base what
they call it they make coke is that why
yeah walk to whip it does that smell it
has a familiar
oh it's not wrong man my nose is so good
i know that smell as soon as i walked in
with oh my [ __ ] lord
this fool does lies i asked him if you
smoked weed before i left you said no
and then do it live but he doesn't
obviously
but i asked like wow
a pretty good nose i knew i smelled that
step
after school right here
right there
but yeah the 94 i guess it's ether base
there it is that makes that's why he
even said it's in 94.
that's what tyler asks on the phone does
this smell like coke do you
i'm so happy i'm right
love it anyway um
yeah man
i think we're getting i think we end
this this this qriket didn't let up
it didn't stop
it's still [ __ ] going
hey man i didn't ask you too many crazy
questions this time you look more
relaxed you didn't go hey man can we cut
that
hey man can we go back
you didn't do that this time
i'm proud of you son
i'm proud of you little kid i'm gonna
teach you how to dunk tomorrow
okay
all right and the day after that i'm
gonna teach you the soccer trick where
you go boom boom boom boom you put your
legs over the ball
you have an exciting weekend
for sure all right
okay and then i'm gonna teach you how to
shave on saturday yeah
because obviously i know him
i'm gonna teach you okay did you say
you're gonna let you're gonna grow a
mustache yeah it's gonna take six years
but i got you
did you say you could do it though yeah
i'm gonna look real sick
i'm gonna look real [ __ ] cool with
just a mustache all patchy i'm gonna
look so tight
marty do you wait hold on marty can you
grow a full beard marty
have you ever grown up yeah look at that
pizzeria guy
okay real quick shitty beard you grow a
quick shitty beard
yeah i don't [ __ ] with beards
yeah nope
i don't like them
yo what are we what are we doing here
what's happening at this point bro i
just said i don't like beards what the
[ __ ] wrong with you this is your show
why are you letting us talk about this
lead the way
what's the next question go
so i'm from merced
okay continue
oh i mean i thought you had the
questions for me
this one's tripping i thought when you
walked in i would be conducting the
interview now how much marijuana did you
smoke
for all the office fans out there good
night
all right man thank you so much that was
fun you didn't eat any edibles you're
super super scared uh you have chocolate
bars here i can't eat those all milk
eat one thing at least i'll eat more of
these gummies you brought out all this
wheat o.g kush 76.
said i have three joints that's enough
it doesn't roll more weed has a full q
[ __ ] two zips over there
it was it was super scared look at him
we're gonna leave the episode saying og
was scared it is halloween
it's halloween it is october you might
just be super scared
he took a bite of a gummy
that's what you know he lost it oh i've
been eating them all damn day that's
when you know he lost it
my ass you lost it
you're good you're no longer
you can no longer challenge me
out of here you can no longer challenge
me and smoke i don't challenge anybody
to like oh i bet you this fool does it
to me all the time
right we started rosin he was like i
took a 1.12 yesterday and i did
1.12 is not real
i'll smoke them all the time
then you know towards the end i had to
let my son win because you know he's
gonna get mad
so he should get that food how to let
him you know okay
yeah me home you know i'm gonna let you
you pick bigger dabs i started him take
breaker dance
remember so i was like all right well
you want me again and that's when you're
you know like
you know you're like little you're my
little proud son
[Music]
you know he was you know so
that's all that's how that's true and
that's why right now i i gave it to him
you know yeah no i understand i gotta
hand it down to him and right now he's
he could all dab me
yeah
because you know did you hear it i mean
it's a season finale
i accept that my son i was about to
break this [ __ ] in half and i remember
this chocolate and i'm so excited he
just said that [ __ ] on camera
all i heard was he cannot out smoke me
out dab me he's so much taller than me
and can dunk on me that's all i heard
mm-hmm no we can play it back but i
gotta get me his locks are deeper dark
than mine that's what he says his lokes
sit better on his face
his team's better than i heard all these
things right now and he can shoot better
threes oh for sure for sure
damn do you hear the end of this show
what a way to wrap up the season goddamn
you know what he's doing
season one's done i finally got him to
admit it's like my mom telling me that
she's wrong
like oh gee like yeah you can outsmart
me man i'm like thank you that's all i
wanted to hear
and now i'm fine i'm fine [ __ ] you
yeah so thank you for that
that's my uh
different voice i did i had hands down
bro you know my legs
yeah my lungs need to rest
he's good he's good now he's seen
looking at him he's good uh-huh yeah
juice now we're doing a second season
just because of that right
all right
not the whole set we didn't do that for
the second season we just did that to do
it
because you said that season two will
come out everybody think oh gee hey one
time i helped og with his ig his
instagram for years
you know then he got deleted and helped
with his new one and then you guys new
one back still won't post so everybody
if you want to say anything on og 70 oh
you know what i gotta change it up then
oh g e push 76. we'll put it at the
bottom of the screen i'll tell you what
we'll tell them go post you know tell me
what you guys want to see if you guys
want to stop just stuff just tell me
weed you smoking weed
so much already like i told you to stop
posting girls now i'm getting reported
for any like a lot of my old wii
pictures they're getting reported enough
then post other stuff that's what i'm
saying oh she with the joint what do you
guys want to see like everything [ __ ]
anything you already know you make you
make you take pictures hey man i've been
trying to get this guy to post on his
[ __ ] instagram
for constantly for about four and a half
years i mean i don't know i'm on
instagram
he never uses it and he finally got he
got deleted for a year got it back still
one post
i mean utilize it you have a following
full utilize it people want to see
what was like the end of the office
daryl people want to follow you on
facebook why are you telling people
you're not on facebook that's you that's
stupid that's you right now
you have instagram but nobody knows it
all right it's og kush 76
it'll have his face on there
all right and me going hateful in the
comments to make sure it's a real one
yeah raw i mean [ __ ] i try to answer as
many dm's i can't you know which is none
for sure how much you post i've been
trying to get this guy when he lost his
account i posted him and he [ __ ]
skyrocketed because people follow him
he's needed a platform to go oh [ __ ] oh
gee got deleted oh [ __ ] what do you do
you didn't post for [ __ ] eight weeks
uh-huh i mean why do you have it if
you're not going to use it well it's not
that they want to post but yeah i mean
[ __ ] everything's so damn [ __ ] you
know i want to lose my account for
posting some weed pick or something
about to do it there's a thousand wee
pics on your instagram huh
you're gonna get deleted by those if
you're gonna get deleted yeah but you
know it's like lately i've been saying
i've been getting reported you should do
you should do full tony robbins
motivational speaking
in the office so today guys i'm going to
tell you how to
finesse somebody out of a lunch and then
have somebody come in hitting camera
[ __ ] but hey could you get my lunch pool
i got you they leave
that's your whole instagram be how to
scam nah just i'm telling you they're
they're [ __ ] they're gonna hack your
instagram start posting dumb [ __ ] though
no what is that called [ __ ] when they
shadow block you or what is that called
yeah i'm shadow man too who [ __ ] post
what
just [ __ ] pose stop being lazy
you have the world at your fingertips
you're in ellie's biggest dispensary
with a grow attached to it who's the
manager oh [ __ ] you
but you don't post anything i'm gonna
slap your [ __ ] leg
all right right across the knee i'ma
smack your knee so hard all right i'll
be honest
he said he's gonna be on it guys ready
after this episode's done
talk to everybody and let them know
after this episode go on his account and
just put
why aren't you posting
i hope there's thousands of people
posting on your account going why aren't
you posting
and i guarantee you
there's gonna be a couple hundred after
this episode i'm [ __ ] i'm counting on
you guys
season one's ending og said i can
outsmart him go [ __ ]
get on his instagram be like yo why
don't you post it's gonna last there
forever people are gonna do it for
months out smoking i mean you start
posting start posting yeah
start posting
start posting guys we're gonna end this
episode i cannot smoke g he can't beat
me madden and uh he's gonna start
posting on instagram
that's he just agreed to it thank you
guys so much for that man
thank you so much for that man i beat og
90 something to 14. i have it on tape
[ __ ] i record justin
how many times i seen your picture of me
beat og by 75 points
oh you're talking about you're talking
about madden oh madden i thought you
said listen madam
i have to let him win bro because now he
won't play me no more if i beat him five
games straight he's not going to play me
i'm like oh yo
marty you know then then we don't have
that son in that time and then
i wanna you know i want to play with him
so i have to let him work marty one time
i facetimed him and this kid was playing
for him
he forgot that i was fine
and his kid was doing the kicks for him
i go bro your son plays for
oh it's just the hard part man i can't
kick well but i'm playing you and you
talk [ __ ] when you win but you're having
your son sub in for you because he's
good at kicking
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] actually he was good
at kicking it was pretty hard if we
played 100 times he's beat me 25 times
for sure there's been times where i got
smoked three yeah
i thought i could win because after that
he won't talk to me
be mad at me
you'll hang up on me and [ __ ]
super sensitive
marty's agreeing making them fools like
is thomas really says about yeah yeah
bro you don't hang up on me talk to me
so finally i go like let's play again
you know i think you can win and he wins
me
yeah i let him win yeah yeah we played
like a hundred times over the course of
three years full so what are you talking
about
we don't play that much
yeah we haven't played in months though
we haven't played
well my controller's broken i try to
[ __ ] play call of duty for the first
time online ever and my controller just
made me guys my spin like that and i
started getting people trying to add
like yo is this real dopes y'all go [ __ ]
i gotta change that name okay
what are you doing [ __ ] what am i doing
man this full sucks dick he plays
youtube videos just can't play video
games my guy was just spitting my
controller's broken i've only played it
five times
it's broken oh god what are we doing
here go get on oh instagram tell them to
[ __ ] post marty it's the end of the
season
marty on instagram and twitter drastic
underscore graphics
right
so guys in this off season we're not
gonna have any episodes until monday
yeah nothing's stopping next week is
season two we're not [ __ ] taking any
breaks eat a dick with that [ __ ] no
breaks whatsoever we're going straight
into season two new set everything going
cool guest for episode one season two
i'm excited
um og actually just got hired as the
janitor but he's not gonna clean she's
gonna stand there with a mob and give
advice it's going to be super sick
right you agreed
[ __ ] yeah
um
drastic graphics on instagram and
twitter mine is yola 2 underscores
youtube 2 underscores that's how many
times i've been deleted
um yola underscore youtube it's linked
in the descriptions of our videos oh gee
you show weed cannot link your instagram
i don't even link my own ins my own
youtube page in this podcast because i
show weed and you know youtube's a jerk
so og kush underscore 76 no no
underscore all one word
oh that's a backup o g e k u s h
that's his instagram that he doesn't use
go leave a comment and say hey post my
story
that doesn't matter
he posted a story anyway
stop asking that question you're going
to read the comments you're going to
read this in 8 months
he laughed he's like [ __ ] yeah you put
me on the spot man
you sit at work while they watch the
videos at your work and you still
haven't watched her [ __ ]
you're the most unsupportive person ever
no i mean like i said you know [ __ ]
i'm cool i'll wait till maybe a few
months after to watch it
it's trash
because you know during the time people
will come up to me like oh i've seen
this i'm like i don't know what they're
talking about then i don't know what you
think yeah i mean
a liar
you just want to look like a liar for a
few months yeah i mean that's basically
what you're saying
this one's the most popular club almost
one of the most popular clubs in l.a
fool's coming in like it's a voice on
the podcast oh what you talking about
bro
well i feel racist like oh [ __ ] was that
not that mexican
[ __ ]
hey man you're making people feel
judgmental
you're openly making people feel
prejudiced
hey i'm sure we're all not gonna serve
you at [ __ ] meet me in paris
all right that's how you're making
people feel like they made you feel at
the restaurant all right ferris bueller
watch the podcast or your prejudice oh
that's a shirt watch our podcast of your
prejudice
season 2
if you're not a racist
yo these are two we're going hard
every guest as soon as they walk in the
door we're gonna have a rim above the
door marty's gonna dunk on him and if
they're like oh i was sick then they can
stay
if they if they get it they can stay if
not
they gotta leave that's fair agree yeah
all right imaginary pinky swear all
right you got that one hey we did it
with the same hands that doesn't work
that's not the way it works
that's not the word there we go oh [ __ ]
this pulls off [ __ ] [ __ ] pinky
swearing [ __ ] yeah look at him looking
over he's [ __ ] combing his mustache
that's
what they do and og's
friend click they put their legs out and
they go okay
and they do that dance that they do like
90s hip-hop that's how they say what up
every time like no handshakes they go
cross ankles
and they hit hands
and shit's actually kind of sick
will your homie remember the one you i
remember i walked in one time i walked
into the dispensary one time and ot is
in the middle of a handshake with his
feet
and then his homie just bat
back flips and as he lands he catches
his hat his [ __ ] guy it was so s oh
[ __ ] right it was it was usher
i'm lying
all right thanks guys um oh geez my
little brother thank you for being on
the podcast little brother um thank you
so much man this is my little brother
ah marty it's the end of the season we
ended it on ridiculous things no better
way no better way
return of
no g
because you [ __ ] got an og pack
[ __ ]
[Music]
it's coming soon uh coming soon
flushed weed awesome
but for now
chest pains
that's i'm gonna start doing that for
all of our [ __ ] drops
black shirt oh that sounds bomb
you can't hear because you're wearing
headphones because you're too cool
but if you had headphones on
you could hear how sick that sounds it
sounds like i'm introducing a number
that's how we should introduce the clips
this clip is og on pcb bam clips channel
[ __ ] man just chug this chuck this we
can leave as soon as you drink all that
we can leave no i'm just kidding all
right oh gee thank you for being here
i'm just [ __ ] with you at this point
i don't know what's going on i'm kind of
[ __ ] up from the tequila
thanks for being here thanks for uh you
know holding back
thanks for holding back
thank you for
fast forwarding if this was a movie you
fast forwarded some good parts and then
went
and then he was dead
that's you storytelling is like it's
like some old man with a remote control
and i appreciate it that's good
well maybe if you had the questions for
me before i would know what the album is
that's not the point in my ass
hey thomas tell us about playing
football so when i played football you
know it was fun i played football you
can't just do that [ __ ] if i i
don't know the question i can't compute
did i spell died wrong
you sure did oh no i didn't okay i
thought he smelled died wrong on my own
notes sorry i just looked past your
[ __ ] head right now
i felt so stupid hey man thanks thanks
for coming just clean all this [ __ ] up
and uh make sure you turn the lights off
all right yeah appreciate you being here
man thank you
all right guys uh this has been [ __ ]
the season
all right og thank you for being here
appreciate you go post on your instagram
marty thank you for [ __ ] editing all
these damn videos and troubleshooting
everything in the beginning rosie thank
you for post mating stuff to us all
season
i appreciate it
that has been awesome lights thank you
for breaking last week
finally held it for 35 the [ __ ] lake
broke the sign fell off
we got the [ __ ] strongest cricket get
the strongest cricket ever i wouldn't be
i wouldn't doubt it if it was a [ __ ]
baby bird nest up there and there's a
[ __ ] newborn it's not their fault
it doesn't sound like
a little bit that's so [ __ ] i do your
own imitation of a bird it's [ __ ] how
do you how do you do a bird noise do it
okay come on do it i'll do the bird like
this go
yeah make the noise of this bird
i'll start doing this this whole in life
all right
guys thank you so much this has been the
first season of dumb
[ __ ] i [ __ ] love the [ __ ] we
talked about marty
marty you can't leave this episode with
no headphones on we have to finish out
like we started this is the end of
season one season one has concluded no
better way
do i hear a plane
no that's perfect and i can't wait for
the the holocaust all right you know
better than me i believe you there's a
helicopter above yeah
yo uh
if a train goes by would only end it
perfectly [ __ ] this cricket since the
aircon episode uh-huh yeah that means
there's a cricket nest in here somewhere
but i can't find it because it's in the
rafters
it comes out at night shoot it
[Music]
don't shoot them they're everywhere
you've said that before
here we go
guys it's been season
thank you for being here o.g
thanks thanks for sitting through this
guys are you ready are you ready
oh now i get it your mustache
it's a t for thomas
oh he's repping me hard
are you going to cut it out i bet you he
was going to cut it now look
mayhew gets mad if i don't you know why
he's like you see he's been a kid
you
know all right if it's really if you
know what shovel it i want you to grow a
shovel beard oh [ __ ] that's dope yeah
what's the girl's shower beard and then
i want you to loop it around your ear
when you don't when you eat
so you're gonna loop it around your hair
get out of yep you made it sound sexual
for some reason did you hear the way he
said that marty felt that that was weird
hey clean this [ __ ] up yeah
i want you to make these walls white but
no paint i want you to clean that off
yeah all right here we go guys thank you
for sitting through season one 36
[ __ ] episodes one audio episode
because me and marty
just haven't done any more audio ones
all right i'm sorry we'll do more
guys go watch the clips channel the
clips channels dope as usual clips
that's uh dope as usual podcast clips
it's always linked in the description
it's on our channels you can just type
it in youtube also
also
bring it up real quick
if you are watching this check your
subscriptions and notifications for some
reason i'm getting hundreds of messages
people saying youtube unsubscribed me
from your podcast
that happens on the dopa zola channel
and now it's starting to happen on the
podcast channel
don't know why we've been not getting
any recommendations whatsoever the last
couple episodes
haven't
gone notifications out i've been looking
at the the chart in the back and the
notifications aren't going out
so we're starting a little shadow band
on the podcast maybe because we're
talking about some [ __ ] that's all over
here smoking crack 13 and [ __ ] maybe
that's why we're getting a little shout
out man but right now check your
notifications check your subscription
button if you were unsubscribed and you
were subscribed leave it in the comments
i want to know how many people looked
and went what the [ __ ] i'm unsubscribed
because it's been hundreds of comments
of just the people that noticed and took
the time to comment so i want to know
how many people actually looked right
now and went oh [ __ ] you're right
so
once again thank you guys so much for
supporting og thank you for being here
marty thank you for editing everything
guys
you turn off the camera
okay i was about to do the outro
guys thank you so much for watching this
season of the dope as usual podcast this
is just season one
phase one we're just uh
we're just getting started
thank you guys thank you for being here
um until next time
have a dope ass day
nice
season one
yeah you didn't cry
i'd have to hold your hand or nothing
i always hold your hand get the [ __ ]
hair
guys thank you season one
season one marty
audio's on
is the camera on hello hello hello i can
hear it
the cricket stopped
hold on
the cricket stopped
the moment you pressed stop the cricket
stopped you're a jerk
joe's apartment with cockroaches
no
marty it really just stopped
we're not tripping
no
that's [ __ ] trippy that [ __ ] you sure
it's not something in the board just
squeaking
nothing just [ __ ] fell asleep the
moment
bro it
it's not for everyone
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]